the SCP Foundation does their best to
live up to their famous namesake they
secure and contain anomalies and
monsters from all around the world or
sometimes even offworld and protect the
public from the dangers that these
strange entities might pose however
despite their efforts to maintain
security and keep their subjects under
lock and key there are sometimes
creatures so clever so devious and so
determined to escape their captivity and
wreck havoc on the world that even the
SCP Foundation struggles to keep them
from getting free one example is SCP
035 or the possessive mask SCP 035 is
one of the most dangerous test subjects
in SCP Foundation custody and its mere
Presence at the foundation has resulted
in Untold damage death and destruction
it seems innocent enough to the
untrained eye The Mask which resembles a
classic white porcelain comedy mask
though it occasionally changes its
expression to tragedy as been in
existence since at least the
1800s in the late 19th century the
foundation discovered the mask in a
sealed cryp beneath an abandon home in
Venice it is unknown how it got there or
how the foundation knew to look for it
if there was ever an explanation for its
discovery that has long since been
removed or redacted from the
foundation's archives you're probably
wondering how can a simple mask leave
multiple season Foundation employees
dead well like everything at the SCP
Foundation this mask Is Not What It
Seems there is a reason its
classification is ker a designation that
refers to an entity that's excessively
difficult to contain and it couples this
difficulty with a pronounced hostility
towards human life and the ability to
cause widespread destruction in the
event of a Containment Breach these are
the qualities that the Poor Unfortunate
Souls assigned to guard SCP 035 would
come to understand all too well the
possessive mask is a parasitic entity
constantly seeking out a host willing to
put it on any human human being in the
mask's proximity experiences a sudden
unexplainable urge to put it on and once
they do There's No Going Back SCP
Foundation research has determined that
once a host has put on the mask their
brain waves are replaced with an
alternative pattern this one coming from
the mask rendering the host effectively
brain dead once the host brain function
has been eliminated the mask takes over
piloting their body and even speaking
through them however the mask can only
occupy a host for a small amount of time
before the body begins to Decay and
decompose eventually rotting away
completely leaving nothing but
desiccated Flesh and Bones where there
once was a person SCP 035 is capable of
possessing any humanoid being whether
that's an actual human being or a
lifeless humanoid shape despite all
their research the SCP Foundation
unknowingly gave the mask all the tools
and resources it needed to break
containment and leave a trail of bodies
in its wake for a Time the mask was
given host privileges meaning that it
was purposely allowed to occupy a host
in order to speak with the scientist
studying it in order to avoid murky
ethical issues the host was usually
something inanimate like a mannequin or
a statue these conditions however
unsettling allowed the researchers to
carry out interviews with the
Consciousness housed inside the mask in
the hope of beginning to understand it
and its motivations however SCP 035 lost
all access to its host privileges after
it almost pulled off an unpreceded ented
shocking and nearly catastrophic escape
attempt in its early days at the
facility when it was still allowed host
privileges it was contained in a tripl
locked room and monitored by several
research Personnel these were
experienced researchers who had been
with the foundation for a minimum of 5
years each an unusually long tenure in
such a dangerous and mentally corrosive
line of work these research staff
members were thought to be the most
capable of handling interactions with
the mask and be able to resist its
attempts at manipulation
unfortunately these assumptions were
naive and seriously underestimated The
Mask power research on the mask
indicates that the mask is incredibly
intelligent and a skilled manipulator it
has a photographic memory intelligence
that would rank it in the 99th
percentile of humans and the ability to
incite dramatic changes in the behavior
and people that it talks to one
particularly in famous interview between
the entity and an unnamed doctor at the
foundation suggested that the mask may
even possess telepathic abilities the
mask was able to give details about the
doctor's life that no one else was privy
to including knowledge of an affair that
his wife was having following the
interview the doctor suffered a
psychotic break and committed suicide
just 24 hours later the mask is able to
use its Superior intelligence
charismatic personality and mindreading
abilities to get inside the heads of
those it speaks with it will pull out
any and all psychological stops to get
What It Wants leaving Broken minds and
Spirits in its wake it was really only a
matter of time before it used this skill
set to its advantage and attempted to
escape its confinement the day of the
escape attempt was like any other the
research staff a team of three
intelligent experienced men checked into
the facility measured the conditions of
the mask's containment unit and began
the process of interviewing The Mask
like normal its motions were slow and
looked to require great effort as its
current host was beginning to degrade
Beyond use the mask was attached to the
blank face of a mannequin and corrosive
black liquid could be seen oozing from
its eye and mouth holes this liquid is
excreted by the mask at a near constant
rate and it's thought to be at least
partially responsible for the
accelerated decay of the host bodies in
spite of the entities's unsettling
nightmarish appearance it was just
another day's work for the men assigned
to monitor SCP
035 and so they carried on with their
daily routine everything was going
according to plan until one of the men
Dr Jones began to behave erratically he
demanded that his fellow scientists
leave him alone with the mask for a
while and allow him to engage in a
private conversation with it it is
unknown what exactly the two spoke about
while the other two scientists were
absent as the security footage captured
had no sound however several minutes
into the conversation in the footage Dr
Jones can be seen dissolving into a fit
of Tears laying on the ground and
shaking with sobs as the mask
dispassionately watches he then climbs
onto his knees begging the mask ask for
something before he Embraces it he holds
the mannequin in his arms for five
straight minutes weeping again before
they separate after this disturbing
emotional display Dr Jones brought the
other scientists back into the room with
him what happened next is still
uncertain but there are a few things
that we know for sure the other
scientists began to speak with the mask
in later interviews the other scientists
were bordering on incoherent babbling
about various traumas from their lives
one repeatedly referred to a drunk
driving accident where a dear friend was
killed and he was at fault another
simply cried out for his mother again
and again whatever the mask said to them
it was enough to completely destroy
their mental health after The two
scientists had been emotionally
devastated by The Mask Dr Jones
escalated the situation further Dr Jones
removed the mask from the decaying
mannequin body and shocking everyone who
had later reviewed the security footage
placed it onto his own face once the
mask was in place the security footage
ends at the command of the Mask which
was now speaking through Dr Jones the
other two men switched off all security
camera monitoring SCP 035 containment
facility The Mask piloting the body of
Dr Jones like a horrible fleshy puppet
made its way through the facility
avoiding detection until it reached the
exit doors where it was finally stopped
by a team of over a dozen security
guards knowing the dangers of touching
the mask all Foundation employees
involved in the recontainment of scp's
035 refused to remove it from Dr Jon's
face instead he was placed in the lock
room with the mask still on left alone
to be observed over the security cameras
until his body had decomposed Beyond use
his body paced back and forth in the
cell for days flesh rotting and dropping
away only until senu and Bone remained
only when the bones began to turn black
and brittle crumbling apart into dust
did the body finally stop moving his
family was notified the mask was
carefully removed from what was left of
his body and his remains were destroyed
the other two scientists involved in the
SCP 035 escape attempt were terminated
and their files destroyed after this
incident a few more failed Escape
attempts and the acknowledgement of the
devastation that could have been caused
if the mask had made its way out into
the general population SCP 035 lost its
host privileges altogether several
research staff protested this decision
insisting that there was more to be
learned from speaking with the entity
and citing valuable information that it
had given about other scps however the
risk was determined to considerably
outweigh the potential reward and the
request to reinstate 0 35's host
privileges were denied several staff
members went so far as to erupt into
violent outbursts on 035 behalf
attacking their supervisors who refused
to provide the mask with a new host
clawing at them with animalistic rage
any staff members that submitted a
request to reinstate said privileges
were considered a security threat and
reassigned to a for an SCP were in some
cases terminated any staff member who
had Direct contact with SCP 035 was also
terminated in order to avoid the risk of
any more staff aided Escape attempts the
mask is now kept in a hermetically
sealed glass case and there is a
psychologist on call to provide
assistance to anyone guarding it in case
of adverse effects on their mental
health from The Masks presence Personnel
that work around the mask even in its
current dormant State experience
frequent violent outbursts and a higher
High rate of suicide even without a host
the mask corrosive effects have spread
across its containment facility the
walls of the room have begun to secrete
the same black liquid that emanates from
The Mask which tests have revealed to be
highly contaminated human blood that
damages the structural Integrity of the
walls following prolonged contact this
blood has begun to form patterns on the
walls spelling out words and phrases in
Italian Latin Greek and Sanskrit as well
as depicting drawings of ritual
sacrifice mutilation staff members also
report hearing unintelligible whispering
and horrifying high-pitch laughter when
in proximity to the mask further
exposure to the mask results in
migraines hemorrhaging around the eyes
mouth and nose and an eventual psychotic
brain between the corrosive substance
appearing on the walls and the physical
and psychological damage to employees
SCP 035 is becoming increasingly
difficult to contain and there are
debates among staff as to whether the
entity can in fact be contained at all
as soon as possible SCP 035 will be
moved into a new containment facility
and its previous cell will be isolated
from the rest of the foundation's
property and destroyed for the safety of
all involved we can only hope that the
new containment procedures are more
effective than the last ones and that
this mask never makes its way into the
world again if it does who knows how
many lives it will claim in the meantime
if you ever come across a strange mask
and feel a nearly uncontrollable urge to
put on ignore the whispered please to
just try it ignore the echoing laughter
and The Sensation of something older and
more powerful than you can imagine
rumaging through your deepest darkest
secret thoughts turn around and run as
fast as you can in the other direction
you'll be glad that you did life at the
SCP Foundation isn't exactly made up of
sunshine and rainbows it's less of a
good vibes kind of place and more of a
this is the solemn work we do as we
stand between Humanity in the vast
unfeeling unknowable realm of mystery
and darkness sure sometimes there's a
magic vending machine or a teddy bear
doctor but most of the time the
foundation's findings are a lot more
bite than they are bar thankfully
there's the C portion of that Infamous
acronym contain they keep their bizarre
astounding findings locked up tight
where they can't catch an unsuspecting
innocent off guard and oh hey there
little buddy it's okay you didn't mean
to scare me relax everyone it's just SC
SCP 999 one of the only contained
Curiosities allowed to roam freely
around the halls of the foundation just
look at this guy has a sentient mass of
translucent orange slime ever been so
cute you want some chocolate buddy okay
here you go it's incredible really that
the place that houses a neck snapping
sculpture in a haunted chess playing
machine could also be the home of such a
delightful little blob you know now that
I think of it it's amazing that being in
the vicinity of unspeakable Horrors day
after day has never put a damper on 99's
positive attitude he's got the
persistent cheerful disposition of a
Labrador puppy but how well would SCP
99's inherent wholesomeness hold up
against one of the most wicked anomalies
contained by the SCP Foundation what
would happen if the lightest of the
light a slimy piece of pure goodness
came up against a deep dark evil not the
omnicidal Rage of SCP 682 we all know
how that went but something quieter well
let's find out SCP 999 was having the
best day of its life to be fair every
single day was the best day of the
tickle Monster's life surpassed only by
the day that followed and the one after
that and how could it not be a good life
at the SCP Foundation when there were so
many friends to play with treats to eat
and so much to explore SCP 999 was
enjoying a hearty bowl of M&M's picking
out and eating the orange ones its
favorites first when a familiar figure
walked into its pen Dr Jack brigh who
frequently came by to see the Tickle
Monster when he was having a
disappointing day usually because the
higher-ups had reprimanded him for
breaking the rules yet again SCP 999 CED
delightfully at the sight of its visitor
slithering over to Dr brigh and
enveloping him in an enthusiastic hug Dr
brigh immediately began to laugh as the
creatures euphoric influence took effect
hey glad there are no hard feelings
about the time I ate a piece of you
H he giggled as 999 patted his face
affectionately with one of its pseudo
pods a thanks that really takes the
sting out of getting the no chainsaws
Hammer brought down on me again he
patted the slime with his own hand in
return and satisfied that it had
sufficiently cheered him 999 ooze back
over to its breakfast to finish
consuming the sugary goodness oh I
almost forgot Dr brgh pulled something
out of his lab coat pocket it was a
small can of cola appealingly shiny in
the light wanta SCP 999 gurgled
curiously and approached Dr brgh to
inspect the can he popped it open with
an inviting Fizz and offered some
fortunately Dr rhs was walking by at
that exact moment don't you dare she
snatched the can out of her colleague
hand you remember what happened last
time 999 can't tolerate caffeine or
carbonation Dr brigh pouted like a
petulant child but I wanted to see it
bounce do I need to add another rule to
the list Dr rhs crossed arms or are you
going to behave yourself GH fine
whatever I'll find something else to do
Dr brigh rolled his eyes and left SCP
99's pen with a final friendly wave at
the creature sensing Dr rh's stress the
Tickle Monster nuzzled her leg with an
inquisitive gurgle she smiled
indulgently and gave the Slime a hug
before she followed Dr brigh down the
hall keeping an eye out for any more
potentially disruptive Antics satisfied
at having cheered everyone up SCP 999
went back to its bowl of can candy and
devoured the remaining Treats but then
there was nothing left to eat and no one
in the room to visit or play with what
was a lovable slime to do why explore of
course SCP 999 had the freedom to roam
all over the foundation site until
bedtime that is and it loved oozing down
the Halls looking for friends to greet
and strangers to meet after all a
stranger is just a friend that the
Tickle Monster hasn't tickled yet as the
Slime slid along the floor it took the
time to say hello to everyone at passed
by bumping them nudging them or in the
case of Josie the half cat very gently
petting her head with one of its pseudo
pods the cat purred and 999 responded by
vibrating its gelatinous body producing
a soft purr of its own then Josie was
distracted by a dust particle drifting
through a beam of light and darted off
to chase it so the Tickle Monster
continued on its way looking for
something new and fun to do it spotted
the perfect new activity two guards were
walking into one of the sealed
containment rooms a room that the Jolly
little slime had never been inside of
before now was the perfect chance to
investigate and maybe play tickle
wrestling with the guards along the way
it had to act fast though the door was
beginning to close rearranging its body
999 squished itself into a long thin
line sliding quickly through the crack
in the door just before it shot this new
room was very messy much messier than
999 was allowed to keep its own room any
spilled chocolate milk or smeared
cupcake frosting was either cleaned up
by staff or slurped up by the slime
itself but in this room there was thick
black liquid dripping down all of the
walls some of it arranging itself into
patterns and words though 999 couldn't
read what they said the guards hadn't
noticed the tickle Monster's presence
yet and it kept still excited to give
them a wonderful surprise when they
turned around and saw that it had
followed them inside but they they
didn't turn around they were completely
focused on something in front of them
what was it it was a thick glass case
that looked as if it was about to fall
apart at any moment inside there was a
mask a porcelain mask of a frowning face
with that same strange dark fluid
dripping from its eye and mouth holes
you know the procedure right one guard
said he was holding a brand new glass
case shiny and completely empty of
course I do the other scoffed it's my
first time with this anomaly not my
first day on the job just open it up and
take the mask out and put it in here he
tapped on the case he was holding as
quickly as possible yeah I just said I
know the less experienced guard grumbled
don't patronize me he reached towards
the decaying case and prepared to unlock
it wait Did you hear that hear what I
thought i' heard never mind scp-999
vibrated with excitement would they give
it some well-deserved attention maybe
play a game but no the guard was wasn't
talking about the eager orange pal
behind him he was feeling the influence
of something much more Sinister do you
want me to do it the more experience
guard offered no just you you really
don't hear that that whispering his
colleague just shook his head fine it's
just been a long week I guess he sighed
and popped the case open reaching for
the mask inside as soon as his fingers
made contact with the porcelain surface
the black goo dripping onto his skin
where he should have been wearing
protective gloves his expression shifted
his eyes eyes went blank like someone
sleepwalking lost in a dream even as
their body moved in the waking World
Frank what are you waiting for the other
guard nudged him but Frank said nothing
he delicately lifted the mask out of the
glass box and before anyone could stop
him placed the frowning white face over
his own only it wasn't frowning anymore
as soon as its features slipped over
Frank's covering him ER rasing him its
mouth curved into a malicious smile
Frank what the hell are you doing the
guard cried out as the man he had once
known grabbed hold of his shoulders not
Frank anymore a voice came out from
behind the ceramic lips but it was
different cruel cold ancient Frank's
gone out I'm afraid and he won't be back
anytime soon the guard tried to break
away from the masked man's grasp trying
to reach for the Emergency alarm to
signal that the containment change had
gone horribly wrong but the mask shoved
him into the wall hard the guard hit his
head and slumped to the ground
unconscious and likely concussed well
ASP 999 has had just about enough of all
of this it hated seeing anyone hurt
especially humans and clearly its help
was sorely needed to make things better
it couldn't tell exactly what had upset
the man in The Mask so much that he was
acting this way but he knew one thing
that always cheered humans up it was
time for a bit of good old-fashioned
tickle wrestling scp-999 hurled itself
across the room enveloping Frank's Body
from his feet to his neck and it began
tickling him as it did the force of 99's
tackle sent Frank's Body careening
towards the ground and when it landed
with a heavy thud The Mask flew off his
face and skittered across the floor now
that I could see Frank's face 999 looked
for signs of laughter of Joy but Frank
was dead asleep eyes closed Jaws slack
his heart was still beating but he
wouldn't wake up confused used concerned
and upset at what it had witnessed in
this new room the Slime slithered along
the floor toward the mask that had cause
so much trouble it seemed to be staring
at 999 with its dark vacant eyes it
didn't look like a toy in fact it looked
like something that the Slime should
avoid touching but it couldn't help but
notice that the face had changed back to
a frown could 999 really leave the mask
there on the floor frowning like that
the Tickle Monster couldn't help it with
a soft greeting by way of a high-pitched
cing noise it reached out to the mask
and picked it up though the Slime
creature didn't have a traditional face
for the mask to sit on top of its
influence quickly grabbed hold of 99's
gelatinous frame it stopped moving
stopped gurgling stopped looking at the
world through rose-colored glasses right
now SCP 999 was being piloted by the
possessive mask and it was looking for a
way out once it escaped containment it
could find a new host a prop host with
arms legs and a mouth but for now this
undignified vehicle would have to do it
took the mask some time to learn how to
Pilot this strange soft body with its
malleable form and odd methods of moving
itself around the room but it slowly
adjusted and wearing the silhouette of
the Tickle Monster like a disguise oozed
out of its containment room and into the
Hall staff walking by barely even
noticed 99's presence they were too
preoccupied with their work they were
used to seeing it and giving at a polite
nod but most of them didn't have the
time to stop and say a proper hello at
this time of day perhaps this would be
easy after all the mask had lost its
chosen host but found something even
better the perfect cover and the chance
to hide in plain sight it could take in
the lay of the land scope out potential
exit routes and ideally slide out of
foundation custody completely unnoticed
The Mask began to smile at the thought
as the mask steered SC scp-999 body
around the sight A peculiar feeling
began to gnaw at the back of its mind
like an itch it couldn't quite scratch
something irritating that wouldn't leave
it alone what was that feeling inside of
its own Consciousness The Mask heard a
sound a sweet high-pitched gurgle no
that was impossible and yet somehow the
consciousness of the Tickle Monster had
survived in the face of the mask's power
it was there still needling at the
mask's darkness with that insipid
insistent kindness shut up the mask
hissed frowning this body belongs to me
now why won't you just die another
gurgle this one even louder more
difficult to shut out did this infernal
thing ever shut up the mask stopped
moving for a moment concentrating the
force of its will it would drive SCP
99's mind away and reestablish dominance
just as the mask was grappling with the
influence of SCP 999 however a familiar
figure turned down the hall it was Dr
rhs from earlier SC SCP 999 exuberance
bubbled up to the surface and The Mask
couldn't stop its mouth from flipping
back to a smile what no that was
ridiculous and yet the longer the mask
was in contact with the vibrant orange
slime so delighted by every familiar and
unfamiliar face it encountered it could
feel that horrible positive influence
growing stronger and stronger it was a
nauseating warm fuzzy feeling that just
made him want on to the mask let out a
giggle then another and before long it
was in the midst of an absolute giggling
fit the mask had laughed before it had
laughed plenty of times but it was
usually a mocking laugh a cackle of
Triumph This was a giggle though of pure
joy the sort of sound a small child
makes as they chase a butterfly through
a field this was the sound of innocence
of happiness it was love Now you listen
to me you VI little worm The Mask
growled it wasn't certain if 999 could
even understand it but it had to show
this rebellious creature who was really
in charge release your grip on me I have
won you have lost your form is mine and
you nothing more than a puppet for me to
pull on your strings and use you to my
own ends show some respect and defer to
me the voice of the Slime creature
whimpered in the mask's mind as sound
like a chastised puppy slinking away
with its tail between its legs H that's
more like it the mask huffed Dr rods
looked up from her clipboard and spotted
that CP 999 she waved about to greet the
creature when she noticed the horrible
mask perched on top she dropped her
clipboard in shock gasping at the sight
no she breathed heart sinking as she saw
one of the purest pieces of good in all
the foundation fall into the forces of
the Mask that's right the mask would
have puffed out its chest if this body
had a chest to Puff I've taken a new
host do you like my selection it
relished the tearful look in the woman's
eyes the horror that caused her hands to
shake and her cheeks to go pale show me
the way to the exit so I might take my
leave of this place and perhaps I will
spare your life the mask was just
gearing up for a good threat a really
nightmarish one filled with vivid
descriptions of Mutilation and violence
when that disgusting feeling began to
rise up again that warmth that buoyancy
it made the mask want to please don't be
sad here let me give you a hug before it
could stop itself the mask slithered the
tickle Monster's body over to Dr rhs
wrapping around her tightly not to hurt
her no to embrace her to comfort her her
horror turned to laughter as the
mood-lifting effect of 99's presence
began to work its magic through her
laughter she was also confused what why
why she couldn't finish the question but
it was enough to break the mask out of
the spell it reared back horrified at
its actions what have I done what have I
done it slithered quickly down the hall
around the corner away from that woman
who had evoked such fond feelings
towards her no towards all of humanity
The Mask steered its body into a
bathroom coming face to face with a
mirror it stared at Its Reflection its
familiar face and dark eyes dripping
their usual fluid perched to Top This
alien thing poisoning its mind what did
you do to me what sort of magic is this
of course 999 did not answer but the
mask could feel its presence could feel
its Delight in the impact it was having
you're ruining me the mask groaned I
strike Terror into Hearts I drive men to
Madness I Rend their sanity into
I it trailed off overwhelmed Again by
The Urge to smile to laugh to frolic
though it didn't have a working nose The
Mask could swear it smelled an array of
heavenly scents of fresh roses breaking
bed in a stone oven vanilla and lightly
burnt brown sugar it reached for itself
with its pseudo pods about to tear
itself off of the slimy body altogether
but it paused ah very clever I see what
your game is it lowered the pseudo pods
brimming with determination you won't
trick me into sparing your life once I
found on my freedom and host worthy of
me I will destroy you once and for all
but even as the mask made this
declaration the black liquid seeping
from its eyes and mouth began to change
to take on a lighter appearance was it a
trick of the light no it was it was
orange like the gelatinous Flesh of The
Horde creature it had made the mistake
of attaching to no matter how hard the
mask fought the influence of SCP 999 was
spreading its mind raced trying to come
up with a new plan a way to hold on to
its identity but the sound of an alarm
blaring outside the bathroom spurred it
to get a move on once more clearly Dr
rhods had alerted someone that the mask
had reached containment time was running
out it needed to find the exit fast it
was now or never The Mask oozed back
into the Hall speeding up as it went
trying desperately to find a way out
before whatever transformation had begun
could complete itself but even as it
struggled it could feel itself changing
warping it burst into Giggles again and
whistled a Happy tune it stopped running
for a moment to wave at an armed guard
and blow them a kiss why had it wanted
to leave this facility in the first
place everyone here was so kind was so
lovely was its best friend no no must
resist must not give into the optimism
to the happiness to the goodness if the
mask had teeth it would have been
clenching them trying to stem the tide
of Joyful noises that threatened to
burst out it felt like something was
tickling it and the tickling just
wouldn't stop stop it the mask dissolved
into Giggles again I mean it he could
feel something coming something big a
loud cracking sound rang out and just as
the guards were closing in on the
possessed Tickle Monster they watched in
awe as cracks spread across the surface
of the possessive mask and all at once
it shattered into pieces the pieces fell
to the floor where they pulled
themselves back together with strands of
black goop meanwhile SCP 999 sat there
bouncing with Glee completely unarm the
Tickle Monster received an extra special
ice cream sunday for its bravery and
amazing work and the mask was returned
to its containment chamber in a brand
new glass case as the mask suffered an
identity crisis for the first time in
its existence SCP 999 curled up in its
pen full of sugar and gratitude and got
some well-deserved rest what does a
monster look like to you what figures
Slither and Claw their way into your
nightmares chasing you down endless
halls and stalking you through the dark
until you wake up screaming maybe you
imagine something tall and lean bony
arms reaching for you from a top
impossibly long slender legs its
featureless face showing no mercy maybe
you think of a man in a striped sweater
with knives for fingers or a serial
killer in a hockey mask wielding a
machete maybe it's something more
inhuman a cosmic horror of tentacles and
eyes that can see into your very Soul
you probably don't think of something
with no arms no legs no body at all just
a face What's So Scary About That a face
can't run after you can't grab you by
the ankles and pull you under the bed a
face can only look it may be unsettling
to behold it might send a chill down
your spine but the worst it can do is
make you a little uncomfortable and if
you can't stand it any longer you could
always just close your eyes or walk away
and be done with it right if that's what
you think if you don't believe in
monsters that can hurt you without
lifting a finger then you're the type to
fall victim to a very special very
intelligent mask in the hollowed Halls
of the SCP Foundation there is a
containment cell outfitted with a
hermetically sealed glass case
surrounded by steel iron and Lead there
are guards posted outside along with a
trained psychologist if you are ever
Brave and foolish enough to enter that
room you'll see a simple white porcelain
comedy mask with a peculiar black
substance leing in from its eyes and
mouth whatever this slime touches
surfaces begin to corrode to rot away
into puddles of black liquid you might
notice the same liquid trickling slowly
down the walls of the room corrupting
everything in its path as unsettling of
a sight as it is if you approach The
Mask to take a closer look you will find
yourself overcome by an intense nearly
irresistible urge to pick it up and put
it on to wear it it to let it consume
you from the inside out and puppet your
body while your brain simply turns off
like an extinguished flame you'll simply
be gone then who knows what the mask
will do it won't be your concern anymore
that's for sure but thankfully you
haven't gone into the room with the
porcelain mask you haven't let It cast
its spell on you not yet at least it's
waiting for you there in the room with
black slime oozing down its walls and it
will wait patiently for as long as it
needs to after all what's a mask without
a face to wear it SCP 035 better known
as the possessive mask sat in its
containment cell immobile as always it
didn't really have much of a choice in
the matter the foundation had chosen
selfishly to revoke its host privileges
once upon a time they offered it bodies
to choose from mannequins dummies and
wooden dolls it could Adorn and pilot
they didn't last as long as an organic
living host of course but it was
something it was a taste of Freedom this
Dreadful new situation was almost enough
to make the mask want to change its
surroundings this Dreadful new situation
was almost enough to make the mask want
to change its expression from Comedy to
tragedy but it was determined to still
find something to laugh about even
without a body trapped in this infernal
box there had been some delicious
opportunities for entertainment human
Minds were fragile things the mask had
learned this over the infinite years of
its life if one could call it a life
apply the right kind of pressure to the
right weak points whisper an enticing
word or two find the right emotional
wound to sprinkle a pinch of salt into
and humans would Buckle completely in
almost no time at all it had tried all
sorts of methods since being confined to
this boring little box sometimes it
would charm someone pour honeyed
flattery into their heads until the
person felt like the mask was a dear
friend a confidant once suitable trust
had been built up the mask could
persuade the person to bring it a host
or perhaps even offer up themselves in
sacrifice if flattery didn't work there
were other potent approaches to take for
a being without ears the mask was a good
listener it picked up on things that no
human ever could the darkest Secrets
buried in a person's mind if it caught
wind of something especially juicy and
ruinous it could leverage that
threatened to expose an affair a crime
or perhaps something even worse
something un un speakable if praise
failed and so did blackmail there was
always good old Supernatural
intimidation all the mask needed was for
someone to be left alone with it for a
long enough period of time then its
invisible tendrils could snake out into
their defenseless mind weaving and
poking around leaving a lingering sense
of cold dread of incomprehensible
Whispers in l dead tongues what a
delight containment had been in the
early days when the foundation had not
yet figured out the mask true
capabilities when they would leave
security personnel with weak wills and
minimal training standing guard in The
Mask field of influence for hours at a
time as the entity played with their
thoughts and chipped away at their free
will thanks to the helpers that had been
able to mold out of those hapless
victims the they had been there to break
open its case and carry it to freedom
but every time the other guards thed the
attempts shooting its helpers and
rendering them utterly useless then the
foundation increased its security
something about the unacceptably high
homicide rates among staff assigned to a
cp035 how utterly boring how truly
pathetic still The Mask had found ways
to occupy it self even without any more
play things it had grown stronger with
its boredom stretching its influence
Beyond Organic beings and into the very
room itself its evil enriching and
deepening like a fine wine in the depths
of a cold cellar over the months the
walls of SCP 035 is containment cell had
begun to secrete the same black slimy
substance that would pour from the
mask's eyes and mouth the liquid dripped
Down the Walls in deliberate formations
patterns that became increasingly easy
to recognize phrases in Italian Latin
ancient Greek all detailing ritual
sacrifices and mutilations The Mask took
time to describe the sacrificial victims
in great detail borrowing identifying
traits from various staff members that
it knew would read the translations the
walls were slick with blood and
harrowing imagery and the glass case
around the mask was growing more and
more Fragile by the day anyone within 10
m of the Mask could feel this strength
too they would leave the area
complaining of unintelligible Whispers
of loud cruel laughter and a lingering
sense of nearly insurmountable despair
it was as if they knew on some level
that no one was truly safe eventually
The Mask would find a way to come for
them all the glass was weakening and
soon the mere thought of Escape would
make it shatter into pieces then perhaps
The Mask could finally get its deepest
desire
Revenge it wanted nothing more than to
try to make the foundation pay for
imprisoning it for taking away its host
privileges for trying harder and harder
to contain the kind of power that should
have had them falling to their knees in
worship the mask seeed with hatred day
in and day out it had seen the crumbling
of the Roman Empire the beheading of
Kings the decimation of armies it was
not going to be captured by a bunch of
rats in labcoats without dire
consequences befalling them maybe it
couldn't move from its prison cell at
the moment but it also knew that it was
surrounded on all sides by Danger ous
beasts capable of reducing the sight and
all who had dared to oppose the mask to
a pile of smoldering Rubble if it could
only find its way onto one of their
faces it would show them all just what
it was capable of as the piercing sound
of an alarm echoed down the hall the
sound of Screams and Chaos following
shortly after the masks frowning face
curved into a broad menacing smile what
was it that had escaped the lizard
perhaps the giant grinning man whatever
it was it seemed that the action was
heading right toward 035 containment
cell perhaps today was the day finally
the SCP
Foundation would fall outside the mask
cell security officer Harper was running
for dear life though his more rational
mind knew he was living on seconds not
even minutes of borrowed time his animal
brain kept his legs pumping desperately
trying to avoid the screaming howling
Predator Hot on his heels Harper looked
over his shoulder and screamed as a long
white arm reached for him scp096 the shy
guy its tooth line jaw hanging low and
foaming with spittle that face that
terrible terrible face an absolute death
sentence to all who saw it he'd seen
what he thought was a crack in the
otherwise perfect seal of 09 six's
containment chamber but it could have
just as easily been a trick of the light
not even thinking he stepped forward and
looked at the vulnerability in the
chamber all it took was one misplaced
ray of light and he made out the vague
shape of a face in the darkness that's
when the Weeping started Harper knew in
that moment his life was over the
correct thing to do would have been to
order everyone else in the room to close
their eyes while he stood there and
accepted his fate minimizing the risk of
spreading the damage further but humans
rarely have perfect reasoning even less
so when facing mortality back in the
present the shy guy made a perfect lunge
grabbing Harper in its iron clutches and
barreling through the adjoining wall the
nearby guards scattered terrified
keeping their eyes on the floor they
might get a slap on the wrist for
temporarily abandoning their posts but
they weren't going to die guarding some
stupid evil mask speaking of the
possessive mask was surprised to feel
too new presences enter its chamber
through the now destroyed wall these two
presences soon became just one as scp096
quickly and totally annihilated security
officer Harper leaving nothing left the
mask couldn't see per se seeing as it
had no actual sensory organs but it felt
around this new guest with its many
psychic tendrils taking in this strange
totality the creature was powerful no
doubt about that and it elicit fear from
those fools at the SCP Foundation but
the mask noticed its brain waves were
extraordinarily muted humans to The
Masks vast and malicious Consciousness
weren't the sharpest knives in the
drawer but compared to this thing's mind
they were a pile of tempered katanas it
barely thought at all the mask would
have to dig deeper to find anything it
could use meanwhile SCP 09 six finally
began to calm down the one who had seen
it had been annihilated bubbling rage
was slowly siphoned out and replaced by
the standard low but constant hum of
anxiety and despair it would wait until
its head was bagged and it was dragged
back to the dark same old same old all
the way to the end of time that's when
it felt something else it started as a
faint Buzz an unintelligible whisper and
it was almost like a door opened in the
back of its head something stepped in
and took a
seat can you hear me
stranger look
look I want to speak to you something
about the voice frightened and comforted
as CP 096 at the same time it spoke with
a greater degree of sympathy than the
creature had heard in a long time and
yet something about the way spoke
implied evil in its
intent I know what you
want I know what you
fear wouldn't it be nice if they could
never look at you
again if you could cover that face of
yours I can help
you it will be so
simple all you need need to do is put me
on little by little 096 felt more of
these strange thoughts filling up the
emptiness in its head replacing the few
little thoughts the creature itself had
it felt itself lifting its hands from
the ground lifting them and reaching
towards something a glass box the glass
shattered and those long white fingers
reached for something within a mask just
like the voice had said a mask to stop
people from looking at its
face
yes yes you're doing so well you're so
close just a little further SC scp096
lifted The Mask to its face feeling
black liquid that burned its skin
dripping from the porcelain and put it
on on and in that moment everything
changed the shy gu's body began to seize
up rattling as the mask Unleashed a web
of psychic tendrils through its body
mapping out across every inch like a new
nervous system taking control the
possessive mask had never experienced a
host like this before that incredible
perfect mix of physical durability and a
mind so insubstantial that it was easy
to sublimate all this was going to be
fun for the first time the shy guy now
under the full control of the possessive
mask stood at full height on its hind
legs its spine and shoulders clicking
into place for its new stance The Mask
cracked its neck getting used to the new
dimensions of its physicality its
indestructible bones its long grasping
limbs its skin burning in and fizzling
with the gooey black secretions but
growing back just as quickly the
foundation had every reason to fear it
now a group of security Personnel had
gathered in the Ragged hole where the
chamber's north wall used to be some
were wielding light Firearms the guard
at the front was carrying an opaque
black bag The Mask laughed with its new
body and turned to the crowd the second
they saw it on 0 96's body their faces
fell for a moment their bodies went SLA
with Terror this situation was
unprecedented what course of action
could they possibly take at a time like
this it looked at the bag held by the
leader of the security force and
projected a single thought into his
mind you won't be needing that before
any of the guards even had a chance to
open fire The Mask lunged forwards using
the long terrible arms of the shy guy to
tear through the guards they were dead
in seconds their bodies strewn about the
hallway The Mask porcelain was twisted
into a wide sadistic grin it could tell
that it was about to have some real fun
around here and once it slaughtered
everyone here it could finally stretch
its legs out in the open again true
freedom to spread misery fear and pain
everywhere it went there were just a few
hundred members of foundation Personnel
it needed to turn into Corpses
more Containment Breach alarm sounded
around the site as the mask began its
Rampage running through the hallways and
tearing apart any unfortunate Foundation
Personnel it could get 0 96's Hands-On
guards researchers administrative staff
and even one extremely unlucky janitor
in hallway C6 it was having the time of
its long and terrible life and much to
its Glee it seemed that this new host's
body was still holding up it was perfect
symbiosis a twisted brilliant mind and a
body that could forever support it there
would be no stopping it a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around
the site soon realized on their own
terms 096 was indestructible but it was
dumb as a brick and had an easily
exploitable weakness get the bag on its
head and you're home free this new
composite creature was a different story
he could think tactically avoiding
head-on confrontations in favor of sneak
attacks and the monster had as much
psychic combat potential as physical
guards roving the building and teams
heavily armed with antimimetic
protective gear still reported feeling
immense feelings of psychological dread
over Cals that was the greatest sign
that the mask would come bursting
through the wall moments later and tear
them to shreds the site director put out
an urgent call for all nearby mobile
task forces to intercept and help them
take care of the unfortunate situation
thankfully a Detachment of mtfa of 10
also known as see no evil was operating
on a case in close proximity given their
specialization in anomalies with a mtic
visual property many on the team had
dealt with 096 breaches before that at
least gave them experience in half of
this situation and one operative among
them Sergeant henrique Ramirez would be
the the one to bring this nightmare to
an end but it would cost him his life in
the process the mask was still using its
new indestructible body to wreck havoc
on the containment site once it had
taken out the primary contingents of
guards it was free to have its fun with
the rest stalking defenseless
researchers through the Halls making
sure to induce maximum Terror before
finally striking the killing blow every
single one of them died with a head full
of demonic Whispers it told them of the
mask's Eternal Dominion now it had found
the perfect host nothing on Earth would
stop it humans would be mere ants under
its feet 8 of 10 touched down and
entered the building Ramirez was
pointman leading the others into the
bowels of the blood drenched containment
site they had been briefed on what they
were heading in for 096 and 035 had
reached symbiosis and were displaying
unprecedented anomalous effects enter
with extreme ction they're beyond
dangerous even more so together than
alone ideally Ramirez would have wanted
to go in with a comprehensive plan but
lives were on the line here they needed
to leap off the cliff and build their
wings on the way down it was only when
they finally encountered the monster
that they realized just how outmatched
they were despite their best efforts the
combined speed intelligence and ferocity
of the mask's new form allowed it to
make short work of 8 of 10 only only
Ramirez was left heavily injured even if
a miracle happened he knew he wasn't
getting out of here alive the mass
grabbed him with one of 0 96's Claws and
lifted him up it would take its time
with this one make him suffer watch him
squirm destroy his mind Ramirez felt the
mask psychic tendrils penetrate the
membrane of his mind those Whispers
those terrible Whispers reciting all his
worst fears with terrible Glee his gun
was out of ammo his knife was broken all
he had left on him was a pocket mirror
and that was his eure a moment it was a
long shot but it was also his only shot
he reached out and grabbed the bottom of
the Mask pulling for dear life his other
hand shot into his pocket and grabbed
the mirror opening its lid with a deaf
flick of his thumb it was too fast for
the MK to even register what was going
on Ramirez forced his eyes shut and
lifted up the mirror the mask saw its
own reflection in the glass as the
bottom of its face came loose revealing
the reflection of the face underneath
the mask squeezed killing Ramirez but it
was already too late it had finally seen
the face of its host and that would cost
it dearly The Mask felt a sudden and
tremendous push back to its psychic
forces a blind Despair and then rage
that choked out everything scp096 began
to sob and howl some how the mask was no
longer in control despite its psychic
protests 096 reached up and tore the
terrible mask from its face tossing it
against the wall with such force that it
was embedded in the brick work its last
thoughts as other mobile task force
operators descended on the area to bag
096 and return it to its containment
chamber were what the hell just happened
and the next thought that crossed the
mind of the site director was request
site transfer for 03 as soon as possible
don't want a repeat of this incident
anytime soon there are some people who
would get tired of being placed in
charge of SCP 914 or the Clockworks the
monotony of it all might make most of us
go mad the same routine day after day
placing an infinite number of objects
into the intake Booth of the machine
selecting one of the modes be it rough
coarse one to one fine or very fine and
seeing just what sort of transformation
takes place but there was one employee
of the SCP Foundation who liked that
routine just fine Dr gears was happy
with his position the Simplicity of the
routine the predictability of it all he
liked when the days stacked neatly
together in a row of uneventful
stretches of time it was why he ate the
exact same meal for lunch every day a
plain turkey sandwich on White Bread a
cup of water and a single banana of
course there was some variety in the
events that came about when testing the
Clockworks there was that incident with
Dr Curtis and the pound of bacon placed
inside the machine alongside a
photograph of SCP 682 it had resulted in
a miniature replica of SCP 682 made
entirely out of bacon capable of
movement and extremely hostile though
its size prevented it from doing any
damage it did still attempt to kill any
staff it could find it had smelled
mouthwatering but Dr gears had suspended
Dr Curtis from testing with CP 914 for
the trouble and a day of having bacon
grease cleaned off of every surface in
the vicinity there was also the incident
that occurred when Dr Herz in an attempt
to score some free music production
placed a CD of his own original guitar
songs into the machine on the setting
very fine rather than improving the
production quality of the tracks on the
CD the machine produced a completely
silent CD as well as a collection of
books on songwriting singing and playing
the guitar for beginners
Dr gears had to physically drag Dr Herz
from the room when upset by the blow to
his ego he attempted to attack the
machine and of course there had been the
highly destructive super bouncy ball
incident which resulted in 45 casualties
and staggering damage to the facility as
well as the aformentioned ball which was
currently thought to be somewhere in
space most likely orbiting Mars but for
the most part it was always the same
thing an object went in a setting was
selected and the object came out in a
new modified State wash rinse repeat
just like it said on the back of the
bottle of the brand of unscented shampoo
Dr gears had been using for the past 30
years that was how he liked it and as he
sat at his desk going over the test logs
and preparing to supervise another round
of tests he turned on some of his
favorite Tunes well I say Tunes but it
was really a white noise machine he
didn't care for music it was was a bit
too much excitement he was just getting
into the flow of his work when there was
a knock at his office door um excuse me
sir a research assistant was standing at
the door pale and anxious a clipboard in
his hands they're um requesting your
help with an emergency down the hall
what is it Dr gears asked they didn't
really say just something about Dr brgh
and um chainsaws the assistant stammered
Dr gears sighed and stood up from his
desk I'll be right there there wouldn't
be anyone keeping an eye on SCP 9914 but
at this point the experimentation
process basically ran itself everything
would be fine if Dr gear stepped away
for a little while wouldn't it meanwhile
across the site a very enterprising mask
became keenly aware of an opportunity
presenting itself it had been lying in
weit meticulously planning and plotting
for days and now there was an opening it
could take advantage of you see months
ago The Mask had managed to finagle
itself a host a researcher who had just
been working with SCP 914 when the mask
Consciousness took over the mans and it
delved into all of his thoughts as they
were snuffed out one by one it learned
all about The Marvelous miraculous
Clockworks the machine capable of
transforming anything into a better
version of itself The Mask had
fantasized obsessed about getting to SCP
914 of using it to mold itself to change
into something greater and more powerful
then perhaps it could escape this place
and return to its former freedom and
Glory of course it would have to select
the right setting one wrong choice and
the whole plan could amount to nothing
on rough The Mask would likely be
destroyed reduced to a pile of ceramic
dust or perhaps even a ball of unmolded
clay alongside some of the black slime
always oozing from its eyes and mouth
UNC course it would likely be
transformed into a slab of plain
porcelain uncarved and unpainted on one
to one The Mask would likely be swapped
out with another anomalous object some
other enterprising mask or perhaps a
haunted Victorian doll or some other
malicious inanimate thing and what use
would that be no that wouldn't do at all
fine could be promising and would likely
prevent the mask from degrading any
future hosts it decided to take but why
stop there why should it limit itself to
Simply fine when very fine was right
there and looking oh so promising it
decided if it could get to SCP 914 it
would find a way to transform itself
using the very fine setting and then its
enemies this pathetic Foundation the
entire world would fall to their knees
it had been waiting patiently like a
snake coiled and ready to snap up its
prey spreading its psychic tendrils as
far as they could go and anticipating
the moment that someone left SCP 914
unattended now the moment had arrived of
course the mask would need help it
didn't have a way to reach the
Clockworks on its own so it had been
wrapping its influence around the Guard
Station just outside its door dripping
thoughts into his head Whispering
Darkness into his ear at every chance it
got chipping away at his will bit by bit
until the man was little more than a
puppet with the possessive mask tugging
at his strings The Mask gave a mental
Yank on one of those strings calling the
man in its thrall into the room first he
knocked out his fellow guard with the
butt of his gun at this point his mind
was so pliable that he would do anything
to please The Mask next the man entered
the containment chamber a glassy vacant
look in his eyes he unlocked the glass
case and reached inside lifting the mask
out and bringing it one step closer to
absolute freedom he tucked the mask
inside of his uniform hiding it away
from any prying eyes and began to walk
steadily towards SCP 914s room all the
while the mask whispered silent
encouragements into the man's weakened
mind promising him power and success
Beyond his wildest dreams if only he
would help it achieve this goal of
course the mask was planning to kill the
man as soon as his task was done but he
didn't need to know that yet every step
brought the mask closer to Victory and
it was practically vibrating with the
delicious anticipation of it all soon so
soon they reached the containment room
the Clockworks just beyond the door the
guard carried the mask into the room
placed the mask inside of the intake
Booth closed it and approached the
control panel in accordance with the
mask psychic instructions he selected
very fine and turned the machine on the
cogs and gears inside were to life the
engine sputtered metal clanked and pipes
exhaled hissing bursts of energy the
output chamber opened and through the
curtain of steam SCP 035 stepped in its
new and improved form that's right
stepped first one long siney leg
leathery shiny and black as the night
extended into view another leg followed
and along with it came a torso a pair of
arms a slender neck and the familiar
face of the Mask stark white against the
darkness of its new body the feet ended
in little points as if the figure was
wearing boots but there was no visible
clothing it was all one being angular
and strange with long long fingers
tipped with curved claws The Mask let
out a wicked cackle throwing back its
head in
[Laughter]
Triumph excellent it's even better than
I imagined The Mask turned to the guard
that had helped it Escape thank you for
your service now I have one last favor
to ask you it was time for The Mask to
test its powers to see how the
Clockworks had strengthened what was
already there what more it was capable
of in this enhanced State I want you to
go into the cafeteria walk into the
kitchen and climb into the oven would
you make sure you turn it on nice and
hot first it waited for a few seconds
before the man nodded solemnly turned
and left the room heading off in the
direction of the cafeteria it listened
as the moments passed and the sound of
horrified shocked screams rang out and
it knew that the man had followed its
instructions exactly at the mask's
orders he had cooked himself self for
lunch The Mask clapped its hands
together cackling
again wonderful oh wonderful now that's
taken care of what shall I try next if
the mask had eyebrows they would have
been arched in a truly devilish
expression first it wanted to test its
abilities on a truly formidable opponent
someone worthy of The Masks time and
attention casually as you please it
strowed over to one particular po
containment chamber to see about an
unkillable reptile as it walked several
guards took notice pointing their
weapons at the mask and ordering it to
stand down each time it chuckled and
with the wave of its hand the barrels of
their guns warped and twisted into
little metal bows completely useless it
snapped its clawed fingers and the
guards fell to the ground in an
unconscious Heap can't have you sounding
the alarm yet the fun is only just
beginning the mask remarked though it
knew the guards couldn't hear it it
kicked open the door to SCP 682s
Containment room with a jaunty
greeting hello you scaly fool I come to
pay you a visit the reptile did not
respond incapacitated by its
hydrochloric acid bath that just
wouldn't do the Mas concentrated and the
steel chamber broke apart acid spilling
everywhere hissing as it splashed onto
any available surface SCP 682 lifted its
head twitching its tail and took in the
sight of the new and improved mask what
do you think the mask posed for the
creature laughing again it seemed it
couldn't stop laughing lately its
expression fixed into a permanent
gleeful smile it couldn't help it
freedom and power just felt so good
disgusting SCP 682 remarked unimpressed
with this display it lunged at the mask
preparing preparing to attack but the
mask held up a hand to stop it not so
fast SC SCP 682 suddenly froze in place
eyes rolling wildly as it tried
desperately in vain to move let's see
what should I do with you the mask was
itching to test out its reality warping
abilities it had the feeling that there
was very little it couldn't do in the
state and wanted to see just how far its
power could go but what would be
suitable punishment what could be the
cruestv it mind perfect it waved its
hand releasing SCP 682 from its
paralysis but as the massive lizard
snapped its jaws and moved to take a
bite out of the Mask it loost lost its
Balance Falling to the ground its legs
had begun to shrink rapidly knocking its
center of gravity as sko soon the rest
of its body began to follow getting
smaller and smaller at an unbelievable
Pace until finally where there had once
stood a massive impossible prehistoric
Beast was something resembling a baby
alligator a tiny little tail thrashing
about short stubby legs bulbous eyes and
a mouth full of sharp but adorable
non-threatening teeth when the shrunken
SCP 682 spoke its voice was high-pitched
and
squeaky it roared yes you are the mask
Turned and Left thoroughly pleased with
its work and shut the door behind it now
what other fellow anomalies could The
Mask exercise its absolute superiority
over it pondered other supposedly
dangerous and deadly entities that it
had heard about over its time in
Foundation in custody it all seems so
laughable now there was only one true
danger within these walls and it was the
mask oh what about that abominable
sculpture the ugly thing with a pension
for snapping necks but only when a
person wasn't looking at it the absolute
coward cowards didn't deserve to live
the mask decided and it made its way
over toward SCP 173s Containment cell
inside there were several d-class
staring at the Statue with wide
unblinking eyes each person terrified of
being the one to let their guard down
and lose their life in the process none
of them would die today however at least
not at the hands of the statue as the
d-class in the cell watched never once
taking their eyes off of SCP 173 the
statue's head began to twist and rotate
the sound of cracking snow and creaking
metal reverberating through the room
The Mask used its telekinetic abilities
to Ren the statue's head from its neck
relishing the irony of breaking the
thing's neck just as it had done to so
many others it wasn't about justice of
course the mask had no taste for such
incepit and human things it just found
the whole image quite funny the entire
thing began to crumble apart like a sand
castle beneath an ocean wave
disintegrating until all that was left
was a pile of Pebbles and dust just like
that SCP 173 was no more as for the
d-class in the cell well the mask could
use some servants you all come with me
the mask ordered flexing its Iron Will
and quickly capturing the weak fear
addled minds of the d-class Personnel
before it they fell in line shuffling
out the door and following the mask with
the same blank Expressions as the guard
before whatever was left of their
personal ities after so much time being
used and abused by the foundation it was
gone now replaced only with the will of
the mighty mask as the mask continued
its Victory Tour of the foundation now
with four mindless servants in tow it
passed the staff break room through the
window it spotted one Dr bright The
Telltale amulet around his neck
microwaving some leftover pizza The Mask
had always found Dr brght distasteful
with a self-aggrandizing pranks and
general dedication to chaos with no
Grand Vision behind it no meaningful
agenda it was pitiful it was deeply ugly
and now the mask had a chance to put an
end to the immortal doctor's Antics once
and for all it opened the door greeting
Dr brigh with that Frozen grin oh doctor
Dr Bright's eyes widened and he didn't
even hear the microwave behind him ding
signaling that his pizza was ready he
was too distracted by the horrifying
sight before him but as he opened his
mouth to scream to call for help the
mask reached out and ripped the amulet
from his neck the ho body fell limply to
the ground and The Mask looked down at
the amulet glinting in the light that
held Dr Bright's Consciousness inside it
stared at the amulet with a flinty gaze
and under its empty stare the metal
began to rust to degrade and to melt
into an unrecognizable slurry The Mask
let it drip onto the floor then when all
that was Dr brght had melted away it
wiped its hand off with a napkin and
ground the wet puddle on the ground with
its heel goodbye doctor The Mask hissed
now what's next but as the mask turned
to walk down the hall it came face to
face with a disapproving face SC SCP 343
had manifested directly in front of the
mask and he clearly had learned of the
mask's behavior so far that day you've
been busy
see yes very busy lots to do you see the
mask chuckled smugly you understand why
I can't allow this to continue right
343's expression remains Stern but calm
you believe you can stop me the mask
tilted its head to the side of course I
can SCP 343 side but you could stop on
your own if you would rather I prefer to
avoid an necessary conflict The Mask
giggled uncontrollably at
[Laughter]
this I am going to Ren the flesh from
your bones it's simply sad I thought you
might say something like that I'm going
to have to take your body I'm sorry s
SCP 343 prepared to teleport the mask's
new body to another location separating
them and reducing the mask to its
original more manageable state but
before he could there was sudden
darkness in the room every light
blinking out all at once the hall was
plunged into Shadow but this was no
ordinary Darkness this Darkness was Inky
thick cloaking like smoke clinging to
the inside of your throat then just as
suddenly as it appeared the darkness
dissipated but SCP 343 was gone he
hadn't teleported himself to somewhere
else he hadn't walked through the wall
to get away from the mask he was truly
gone the mask couldn't be certain
exactly what it had done to SCP 343 but
it knew that the enemy had been truly
eradicated in fact it was fairly certain
he had been erased from reality entirely
The Mask made one final lap around the
foundation containment site bidding
farewell to every anomaly it passed some
it transformed like it had done to SCP
682 taking inspiration from its birdlike
face the mask turned the plague doctor
into a crow others had simply executed
such as the poor scp096
whose screams and shs had always
irritated the mask of course the
foundation began to notice what was
happening and they tried to defeat the
mask they shoted it with their puny
weapons they sounded their useless
alarms and they called for their laugh
backup but none of it mattered not in
the face of the Mask guns melted in
guard's hands alarms went silent at
nothing more than a glance and more and
more Mindless slaves joined the masks
Army it didn't want too many that would
just be difficult to keep track of but
an even dozen seemed like the perfect
number with this miniature Army in tow
the mask finally made its way to its
final destination the exit it had been
waiting for this moment dreaming of it
since it was first imprisoned so long
ago as it stepped out into the Sun the
mask realized that though it didn't have
nostrils could smell the breeze the
scent of wild flowers and grass what a
beautiful place to mold into the mask's
image of an Ideal World the world was
its oyster and The Mask longed to
swallow it whole the current whereabouts
of the possessive mask are unknown the
foundation is doing its best to locate
the mask and determine new effective
measures for bringing it down and
recontain it as soon as possible The
Escape of the Mask is being considered a
possible XK Class end of the world
scenario if it cannot be stopped the
best and brightest Minds that the
foundation are working on it aside from
Dr bride of course may he rest in peace
but right now there is very little
anyone can do so if you see a strange
dark figure in a white mask walking down
the street do yourself a favor and run
the other way before it's too late here
we are again with the
anamatronics of some of the world's most
bizarre scenarios whether it's scp096
versus siren head able versus chainsaw
man or now perhaps our most ridiculous
matchup yet SCP 035 the Diabolical
possessive mask versus The Mask the
popular Jim Carrey character based on
the hyper violent comic book of the same
name so what the heck are we waiting for
let's crank up the machine and see what
the results are somebody stop me okay so
what have we got on intake today
researcher wereb asked a tone of boredom
hanging off his every word uh possible
anomalous entity his compatriot Dr mne
replied sipping his coffee sounding
equally as unenthused Caucasian male
early 30s a team of our agents picked
him up in the foundation doctor checked
his notes some place called Edge City
real appealing tourist spot he added
sarcastically now what's so anomalous
about him worb question his eyes lazily
scanned over a file mne had handed him
says here he's just an ordinary bank
teller there's one prior arrest on his
record but the charges were dropped
later on and this guy's a nobody
apparently he was in possession of an
anomalous artifact came the doctor's
reply he looked through the one-way
glass into the interrogation room sat at
the table wearing a matching pair of
hideous pajamas was a wiry brown-haired
man what was it researcher wereb asked
not bothering to check the file a mask
apparently mne replied this thing can
form a symbiotic connection with whoever
wears it this guy's had it for a while
it causes him to undergo a dramatic
intensification of his personality when
he puts it on as well as granting him
some uh unusual abilities hold on aren't
you just describing SCP 035 worb said
looking confused nope the doctor
responded by handing him a clear
evidence bag in it was a single wooden
mask a dull darkish green tint to the
object it looked to be almost Viking in
its design with three holes on its
surface one for the mouth and two for
the eyes it was hard to deny it was
completely different from the white
porcelain of SCP
035 what's this guy's name again worb
side looking at the scruffy pajama clad
man waiting for them ipkiss his
colleague replied Stanley ipus meanwhile
locked up tight in a hermetically sealed
glass case was another anomalous mask
SCP 035 was kept under lock and key by
the foundation guarded constantly by a
pair of armed security officers one of
them officer rert had noticed something
strange about the infamous possessive
mass today or stranger than usual anyway
SCP 035 was known to compel people to
wear it if they were close enough often
through subtle psychic Whispers but
today it seemed Restless almost agitated
like it found something nearby to be
intensely annoying I already told you
everything I know Stanley IUS sighed
exhaustedly he'd been dragged out of bed
at the crack of dawn by strange agents
and was now being interrogated about
what he knew of the wooden mask he'd
come across floating in the river one
fateful night I don't know where it came
from I swear I didn't even realize I
still had it uh we threw it back in the
river but my dog must have out and
fetched it Stanley explained you have no
idea what this thing is not even from
any firsthand experience Mr ipus Dr mne
asked holding the mask up look I did
take it to a psychologist who told me it
might be Scandinavian a representation
of some Norse Knight God the Loki I
think he answered we're not interested
in this mask as a historical artpiece
researcher worb retorted tell us what
happens when you put it on Stanley
paused for a moment clearly aware he was
in real trouble but nervous about
coughing up the details to his Shady
captors with a sigh he decided it was
best to
confess I don't know how it works but
whenever you put it on it's like it
brings your deepest desires to life when
I wear that mask I can do anything be
anything he described remembering a key
detail but it only works at night Dr mne
and researcher worb exchanged looks
uncertain if ipkiss was just a lunatic
or if there was truth to what he was
telling them assemble a security team
mne sighed we'll arrange a safe
environment for you tonight Mr episs
elsewhere in the facility rert and his
fellow security officer Dugen was
watching over SCP 035 with growing
concern what do you reckon has this
thing so agitated Dugan wondered aloud
who knows rard side Avari reported it to
command told them 035 is in a mood they
said to proceed as normal suddenly as
the words left his mouth officer rard
felt strange it was like he had been
hooked by an overwhelming urge to put
the possessive mask on he barely noticed
he had reached to unlock the door
sealing the area where SCP 035 was
contained in its case and as he stepped
through officer Dugan's pleased for him
to stop barely registered the other
officer tried in vain to pull rard back
as he walked towards the possessive mask
only to feel his coworker grip his shirt
and swing him face first over and over
again into the glass case containing the
anomalous object his body going
completely limp after being used to
break the glass rer dropped Dugan to the
floor too lost in his trans-like state
to realize he just killed a fellow
Foundation security officer he was too
focused on SCP 035 as he lifted it up
and placed it over his face meanwhile
Stanley ipus had been brought to a
testing area a team of security officers
standing around him the fact that they
were all armed did little to ease
Stanley's nerves Dr mcne strowed up to
him pulling the green wooden mask out of
the airtight bag it had been sealed in
and handed it to Stanley no funny
business Mr IUS the doctor warmed I
really can't promise that Stanley
replied he looked at the mask in his
hands noticed a green Shimmer over the
reverse side of it as much as he had
gladly given it up part of him had
missed wearing it he could already hear
the low rumbling of thunder outside as
he lifted it towards his face feeling it
almost leap out of his hands and latch
itself onto him the green mask eagerly
became attached to Stanley the surface
of it spreading out where it covered his
face and wrap around his entire head
around him the guards cautiously stepped
back as they watched Stanley convulse
and WTH around the place uncontrollably
like a man possessed both researcher
word and Dr mne looked at each other in
wordless disbelief before turning back
to the scene unfolding Before Their Eyes
the booming noise of thunder and cracks
of lightning rang out despite this all
taking place indoors as Stanley ipkiss
vanished in the center of a miniature
tornado that spun wildly around the
testing area before slowing to a halt in
its place stood a maniacal wide-eyed
figure dressed in a garish yellow zoot
suit and wearing an enormous tooth grin
on his bright green face how do fellas
the mask bombastically hooted at the
guards having been trained to deal with
absurd anomalies of Plenty the security
Team all defensively raised their
weapons out of a mix of instinct and
confusion is rough crowd The green-faced
Lunatic stated to nobody it looked like
he had turned aside as if addressing
some invisible audience outstretching
both arms and one leg The Mask instantly
zipped off hurling around the room in a
whirlwind of absurdity in the style of
an old Tech saory cartoon the spinning
cackling combination of Stanley ipus and
the Magical mask weaved in between the
foundation guards all of whom tried in
vain to restrain him until he
disappeared out of the door after him Dr
mne yelled with urgency in his voice the
guards all turned to run after the mask
only for each one of them to trip over
and land face first on the floor of the
testing area as if something had tied
them all up by their ankles it was only
after the security officers all
struggled back up to their feet that
they noticed their pants had been yanked
down leaving the foundation's finest
somewhat embarrassed to say the least
outside the testing area Stanley or
rather the mask had already closed the
door behind him out of nowhere he
produced a series of wooden planks and
began h hammering them into the door
frame boarding it up before speedily
adding chains and padlocks to the mix
sighing and in an ere exaggerated manner
wiping the sweat from his brow he turned
around only to be met with the sight of
even more SCP Foundation guards lying in
weight their guns all trained on him the
mask gave a scream of pure Terror that
briefly sent his skull popping out of
his head and his eyes shooting out of
his skull before everything zipped right
back into its original place his eyes
started around at the faces of the
foundation security wondering how he was
going to get out of this one oh gee this
all seems familiar he said either to
himself or his audience well if it ain't
broken hit it in the blink of an eye the
mask's bright yellow outfit had
transformed replaced by a silk blue
Rumba shirt with ruffled sleeves white
pants and a wide brim black hat as they
watched him stood at the ready a few of
the guards noticed the sound of music
not one of them could tell where it was
coming from nor could they help starting
to tap their feet or Bob their heads to
the r of the Cuban Pete Rumba the entire
security team quickly erupted into a
full-blown dance number that anyone who
saw it couldn't resist joining all led
by The Mask wildly waving Maracas in the
air and singing elsewhere in the
facility officer rert was beginning to
melt he still had SCP 035 covering his
face the frown of the possessive mask
conveying the entity's sheer discontent
the black ooze secreting from its
porcelain surface had the unfortunate
effect of corroding and melting down
anyone that wore it dissolving them
entirely after a short period of time
determined SCP 035 pushed on plotting
its host towards a storage room if it
remembered correctly the SCP Foundation
had stored a number of temporary hosts
for it mannequins that while not human
had enough of a humanoid shape for the
possessive Mas to use of course after
all of its attempts to escape the
foundation had rescinded its privilege
to be granted new hosts not that could
stop it from taking them by force using
the last of Officer riger's dwindling
strength SCP 035 bared its way into the
store room sure enough waiting there for
it was a row of discarded mannequins
lifting riger's hands before they had
fully melted away the possessive mask
used him to place itself on a new body
elsewhere not too far away in the
foundation facility a conga line of
security officers and research Personnel
was parading through the corridors all
happily dancing andum ding to the music
despite still no one being able to
figure out where it was coming from
dashing away from his spot at the front
of the line the mask zipped around a
corner his clothes having changed back
to his signature brightly colored Zoot
Suit never say no to a potty he
exclaimed after having danced his way to
Freedom the sound of something shuffling
closer quickly caught the mask's
attention he turned around to find
himself standing green face to porcelain
face with SCP
035 you the masked mannequin raised a
hollow arm pointing a finger from its
host at Stanley you be the god of
mischief's carving I could sense its
presence since you arrived still in my
look nobody likes a copycat F The Mask
replied although intimidation is the
sincerest form of flattery and that's
how Jim K's career
started he added exploding with rash's
laughter cease your prattling SCP 035
hissed with spite say perhaps we're
related The Mask ignored it oh we could
be long lost family you know I always
wanted kids of my own Son of the Mask
has a nice ring to it right he paused
once again turning away to his unseen
audience on second that maybe not the
SCP 035 controlled mannequin leapt
forward gripping the mask's arm causing
him to scream in shock at the advanced
his eyes bulged out of their sockets
zooming in on the corrosive black
secretions oozing from SCP 035 the
mannequin's other hand started reaching
upwards gripping his oversized green
head as if it were trying to lift the
mask right off of Stanley's face zooming
away again he sped down the nearest
Corridor his arm stretching behind him
still clamped in SCP 0 35's grip coming
to a screeching halt with the comical
sound of car breakes The Mask wobbled
his outstretched arm a ripple traveled
all the way along the elongated limb as
if it was made of elastic his wrist
still being held by the mannequin
sporting the possessive mask the force
of of the flailing rubbery arm was so
great that it flung SCP 035 is host body
around sending it head first into the
ceiling then plummeting back down to the
ground its grip loosened allowing the
mask to reel back its stretchy arm
although it didn't return to normal
length right away his own hand pinged
back and hit him in the face only to
start urgently trying to communicate of
its own accord what's that boy The Mask
said to his hand as it started
performing a series of signals little
Timmy stuck down a well you like a
Friday night off there's a two- bit
chump wearing another mask walking
menacing down the hall towards us the
hand suddenly turned the mask's head to
look in the right direction sure enough
SCP 035 was using the mannequin to walk
down the hall towards him his elongated
arm quickly returned to its normal size
as the green-faced lunatic took a quick
draw stance facing his oncoming
adversary now you have to ask yourself
one question he sneered doing a fairly
convincing impression of a green Clint
Eastwood do I feel lucky with a sweep of
his hand The Mask had drawn an enormous
weapon the thing was a gigantic mass of
different artillery clicking and
worrying there were barrels on top of
barrels rockets and other explosives
locked into place do I feel lucky The
Mask continued well do you punk SCP 035
did nothing to slow its advance so the
mask pulled the trigger every one of his
weapons various components spat out a
tiny flag with the word bang written on
it ah performance issue he said doing
his aside once again not that I'm
overcompensating for anything clearly
growing agitated piloting its host SCP
035 started charging towards the mask
immediately he spun around becoming a
tornado of hyperactivity and whooping
noises as he sped down the adjacent
Corridor the possessive mask staggered
after him the Ooze leaking from the
porcelain anomaly was Dripping onto the
mannequin wearing it causing the plastic
to be melted away exposing the flimsy
metal skeleton beneath it knew it had to
merge with a new host find something
else to corrupt SCP 035 chased after the
cartoonish Troublemaker knowing that if
it could catch him he'd be able to
survive merging with it his body while
wearing the other mask barely obeyed the
laws of physics making him invulnerable
to damage and possibly even the
corrosive substance oozing from the
possessive mask as if those weren't
enough reasons his power seemed
virtually Limitless combined with a
green-headed lunatic
cp035 could do anything reaching a stop
at the end of another Corridor The Mask
spun around wearing a comically
undersized baseball uniform he reached
into his pocket and produced an
oversized baseball bat then proceeded to
start hurling baseballs into the air and
swatting them as hard as he could as the
mask increased the speed of his swings a
volley of hard cork baseballs were fired
down the corridor like a barrage of
bullets ricocheting off the walls and
hitting the oncoming SCP 035
each one struck its Target reeling the
mannequin but doing little much else to
stop it getting closer and closer until
With An Almighty swing The Mask brought
his Bat crashing into SC SCP 035 with
enough Force to send the possessive mask
and its house kening down the corridor
it sailed through the air bursting
through a wall then flew into a research
lab tearing a huge hole in the next wall
as it kept going finally it came
crashing out of the last wall the outer
wall of the facility and dropped
multiple stories to the ground outside
changing costumes back to his classic
suit and dashing after SCP 035 The Mask
passed through all the holes his
adversary had left in the multiple walls
it had crashed into he screeched to a
halt again and paused after getting
through the outer wall only to realize
after a moment that he was hovering in
midair not standing on anything reaching
into his suit pocket The Mask pulled out
a sign on a stick with a single word
written on it yikes he plummeted down to
ground level Landing with such an
immense crash that his body cracked into
the asphalt below it left a perfect
outline of him imprinted in the ground
causing the mask to go completely
pancake flat head to toe suddenly before
he could peel himself up off the ground
and go back to being three-dimensional
SCP 035 staggered to its host's feet and
pinned The Mask down finally it growled
I've caught you I've won your power is
mine once I've combined with you I will
be able to ravage this world I'm going
to fuse to your face then I'll start
with decimating those wretches that
imprison me the foundation will fall and
then so will the rest of their precious
World forcefully the mannequin's hand
wrenched the mask off the ground but as
SCP 035 turned to look at what it had
hoped to be its next host well let's
just say the tragedy frown carved into
its porcelain face had never been more
appropriate it wasn't holding the mask
it was holding a life-size cardboard
cutout of a photo of the Mask grinning
out from one side enraged the possessive
mask tore the decoy in half with its
mannequin's hands hey puko said a
cartoonish voice from right behind it
did you miss me the mask had reappeared
for real this time grinning with his
huge teeth clearly getting a kick out of
having someone to torment SCP 035 on the
other hand had been getting increasingly
irritated by all the wacky cartoon
Antics with all the aggression it could
Channel through its mannequin host he
gripped The Mask by the throat his eyes
bulging out of his head again see you
need to get all choked up over it he
gagged you are so tiresome the
possessive mask yelled having finally
run out of patience you know what I
won't merge with you I should just kill
you and put an end to your buffoonery
let me take this thing off you first
though it's mannequin fingers started to
hook into the mask seam at the back of
his bald green head wait wait the mask
bag putting up both his hands in
surrender at least give me a final
request huh Master mask before the
possessive mask could respond the mask
had swept it off its dissolving
mannequin feet he started to spin it
around in a wild over-the-top dance
number bopping and Swinging to a tune
that seemed to be coming from nowhere
the longer it went on for the more and
more of SCP 035 host's body started to
dissolve away until the mannequin
finally wasted away all that was left
was a bubbling pile of black goo on the
ground with the possessive mask laying
in the middle The Mask chuckled noticing
the fumes trailing upwards into the air
as the corrosive substance melted away
the last of SCP 0 35's host talk about
smoking he had it he still couldn't
believe that he had it very few
professional thieves managed to steal
something so valuable right from under
the nose of the SCP Foundation and even
fewer Liv to tell anyone about it Kasden
gripped the bag in one hand holding on
to to it so tightly his knuckles felt
like they might split he was drenched in
nervous sweat the clam of his palms
leaving an imprint on the material of
the duffel bag its precious contents
moved around Loosely every time it
jostled and knocked against him Casten
had to fight the urge to unzip the bag
just to remind himself this was all
actually happening but he resisted he
knew the mask wanted not only to be seen
But to be heard as well the earpiece is
had provided was doing its job keeping
the Whispers at Bay dampening the
telepathic Aura enough to ensure that
casden retained control over his own
faculties the bag he'd been told would
also hopefully dampen the powers of the
Mask corrosive fluid he'd been prepped
extensively for this job more than any
other in his long and storied criminal
career it had taken months of planning
staking out the home of a foundation
researcher stealing his access card and
slipping in into the heavily guarded
facility undetected as if that hadn't
been hard enough he then had to find the
right containment cell containing what
he'd been hired to steal just like any
Heist the timing was everything he had
to make sure he was there on the exact
day the glass container housing his
Target was due to be replaced thanks to
corrosion damage having been gradually
melted and worn away over time at an
intensely precise moment on precisely
the right day casden had to enter the C
and toate not only the research staff
that had come to swap out the glass
container but the armed guards posted
outside too then it was just a case of
slipping on the specialized gloves he'd
been issued grabbing the mask and
stashing it in the bag with protective
lining to stop it from being corroded
during Transit All Things Considered
Casten had been doing pretty well given
the circumstances that was until he
heard the blare of alarms ringing out
his heart which had already been
drumming away in his chest through sheer
nerves now began beating so fast it
threatened to crack his ribs Panic shot
through his entire system and at that
moment all sense of rationality was
dropped faster than a lead balloon any
further attempts at subterfuge were
pointless why keep hiding surely the
alarms were for him cast in thought and
immediately started running losing all
cover he barged past a pair of
foundation researchers in lab coats
knocking them both to the ground found a
storm of paper files they'd been
carrying were hurled up into the air a
temporary smoke screen to cover castan's
Panic Escape one foot launching past the
other he barreled down the facility's
corridors the same way he'd come in if
he was quick he might make it before
they sealed the exits and trapped him
inside the chances were slim and Casten
knew it but he was left with no other
choice apart from letting the SCP
Foundation catch him hauling him off to
God knows where for interrogation he
barreled past more Foundation staff some
of them holding their hands out to try
and stop him as they figured out what
the alarms were for and why Casten was
running shoving one out of the way he
felt something snag at the lab coat he'd
worn as a disguise one of the
researchers had him kicking a leg back
Casten clipped the man's knee and
whipped himself free of the coat not
letting him stop from running he was
close now so close to the door he'd come
in through if he could just pass this
corner he'd be home free the clump of
multiple heavy steel toed tactical boots
came rushing through the entrance to
meet him a squad of men one of the
foundation's infamous mobile task forces
were hurdling towards Casten like a
tidal wave wearing all black combat gear
he skitted as he tried to turn back the
way he'd come stumbling over his feet as
he was chased by the sound of angry
shouts commanding him to freeze drop the
bag and get on the ground Caston dared
not look over his shoulder catching
hints of the oncoming MTF agents in his
his peripheral vision compelling him to
keep running but with no idea where to
go and four heavily armed operatives
clipping at his heels there was little
hope of escaping now a powerful weighty
force struck castan's back knocking the
air out of his lungs as it pushed him
over and kept him pinned to the floor he
could barely move as the agent tackled
him gasping as he desperately tried to
pull his breath back the rest of the
squad gathered around him all yelling
and warning him not to move but there
was another sound no another voice
drowning out the soldiers the earpiece
the one thing keeping his mind safe it
was gone it must have fallen out when he
hit the ground and now the mask could
get in the whispering was unintelligible
nonsense really Casten couldn't clearly
make out what it was saying he only knew
it had quickly become the only thing he
could hear and how it made him feel he
had to put the mask on it was such a
strong compulsion it felt like so much
more than a want a desire to wear it it
was a need the bag was so close dropped
to the floor where he had been tackled
if he could just reach it and tear the
zipper open he'd have the mask in his
hands rolling over Casten lashed out at
the MTF operative catching him by
surprise as his fist connected with the
man's balaclava covered face the agent
was stunned lifting some of his weight
that had been pinning the thief down
just enough for Casten to freeze his
other hand another pair of Agents tried
to hold his flailing arms to the ground
only for him to reach up and pull one of
them face first into the concrete floor
with a bloody crunch with every ounce of
strength he could muster cast and moved
like a man possessed hurling the agent
on his other arm into the first who had
tackled him slipping out from underneath
the crumpled agents he crawled on his
stomach as far and as fast as he could
Casten desperately scrambled for the
duffel bag it was so close airor a few
inches away his fingertips brushing up
against it as he reached but he couldn't
grab it as much as he felt that
overwhelming need to his feet were still
buried under the weight of the MTF
operators and their gear stopping him
from reaching any further until one of
the agents moved just enough to free
caston's foot everything seemed to move
in slow motion the MTF soldiers were
reaching out to pull Casten off the
floor as his hand shot forward and
tightly gripped the straps of his bag he
could feel hands wrapped in tactical
gloves gripping at his shirt in that
same instant he wrenched the bag towards
him and pulled down the zipper he had to
get what was inside even if it killed
him he barely noticed his earpiece
getting crunched under the heavy combat
boot of one of the agents instead he was
inhaling fumes from the interior of the
bag its specialized inner lining already
melting thanks to the viscous black
substance secreting from The Mask casden
didn't even register the pain in his
hands when he reached inside the
secretion corroding his bare skin as he
retrieved what he' been hired to steal
what he so now desperately needed to put
on his face SCP
035 the possessive mask time felt like
it had ground to a halt freezing
everyone Casten stared for a split
second at the white porcelain surface of
the Mask it felt like it was glaring
hatefully at him thanks to its
exaggerated tragedy Grimace it was
almost as if it disapproved of Casten as
if he was some how Unworthy of it but
holding it in his hands the compulsion
to put on SCP 035 was now so unbearable
oblivious to the foundation agents
around him who were trying in vain to
restrain him again Caston tipped his
face into the mask and everything went
black it was like being half asleep his
awareness of certain things Stripped
Away things like the pain searing his
face a gradual acidic burning that was
eating away at his flesh corroding his
body and yet Casten could still feel
occasional Sensations Tremors running up
his arms as his fists made contact with
something then pulled back and struck
again leaving behind something wet on
his knuckles but he couldn't see all
around him was shrouded in darkness he
knew his body was moving maybe even
walking taking him somewhere but he had
no clue where and no control anymore it
was like someone something else had
pushed his mind out of the driver's seat
and now had both its corruptive hands on
the wheel his mind was now lost in the
Blackness shut down gone it was only
when he came back around that Casten
felt the sheer unrelenting Agony fully
wash over him the mask was off again
leaving him a scorched screaming mess he
was laying on the floor of another
containment cell this one was different
from the one he'd stolen SC cp035 from
it was less heavily guarded minimal
security it might not even have been in
the same facility Casten had no idea how
long he'd been wearing the mask for all
he knew apart from the intense pain of
the corrosive black sludge breaking his
body down and the blood stains on his
hands and clothes was that he wasn't
alone someone else was there with him
Kasden didn't know the strangest part of
all of this he should be dead no he was
dead much like Dr Brit's Medallion the
possessive mask typically wipes the
human mind like oxyclean if he was bad
back it meant somebody brought him back
somebody with truly great power craning
his head up he caught sight of the
cell's only other occupant even
squinting through his stinging eyes
Casten couldn't make out exactly where
the other men was from only that he was
much older he was looking down at Casten
writhing on the floor there was
something almost sad lingering in his
eyes there was a kind sympathy behind
them not just from looking at someone
with such severe injuries but an almost
apologetic gaze like he was sorry that
the pain even existed in the first place
glad to see you back my son the old man
said it's been a while since I've needed
to pull someone back from that deep in
the darkness I was worried I'd be a
little rusty the old man gently reached
a hand out towards him and took caston's
pain away he didn't heal him not fully
just hit paws on his wounds but before
he could thank the kind stranger The
Masks started whispering again only this
time it was calling to the old man no
longer hurting but still reeling from
what SCP 035 had done to him Casten
tried to stop the man calling with a
rasping voice begging him not to listen
to the possessive masks call he didn't
seem as Spellbound as Casten had been in
fact the old man almost just looked like
he was going through the motions pacing
over to where SCP 035 lay on the cell
floor picking it up and just like Casten
had done he lifted the porcelain mask
over his wrinkled wisen face helpless
unable to do anything other than watch
on in horror casden couldn't help but
notice the tragic frown carved onto the
surface of SCP 035 had shifted now it
was a wide gaping smile a comedic grin
with nothing but ill intent behind it
while he had no idea who the old man was
some swirling sickening feeling in the
pit of cast stomach told him nothing
good could come from putting that
Twisted mask over another anomalous
being if he had only known that SCP 343
was colloquially nicknamed God by the
foundation's staff and was widely
believed to be the sole creator of the
entire universe then Caston would have
used all his strength to pull the mask
off of the old man's face and Smash It
To Pieces but it was already too late
the very second the possessive mask
slipped over SCP 343's face the ground
shook violently ly like the very Earth
itself was afraid of what had just
happened still watching from the cell
floor casden looked at this combined
creature it Stood Still For a Moment
slowly breathing through the mask before
it lifted its hands and appeared to
examine them the comedy smile on SCP 035
made it seem like the mask itself was
looking with a warped sense of Glee at
its new host body more of that same
black goo was being secreted out from
Beneath The Mask drops of it were
rolling off the old man's shoulders they
landed on the cell flooor melting tiny
burning holes as the substance dripped
down through the concrete and steel of
the facility his body being preteer by
the mask on his face the old man wiped a
smear of the sludge away with his hand
looking at it in his fingers it wasn't
melting him the same way it had to
Casten usually the corrosive secretion
that SCP 035 naturally produced proved
to be its weakness melting the bodies of
its human hosts and eventually
destroying them leaving the mask without
a form to Pilot SCP 343 on the other
hand was only humanoid in shape and far
beyond any mortal being that the
possessive mask had ever enthralled the
combined being corruptive mask and
omnipotent God raised its hands high
like a conductor before an orchestra
from the spot he lay in Casten watched
in horror as every member of Staff in
the facility was pulled up through the
floor or dragged screaming through the
walls piping and brickwork ter ing
through them this was a minimum security
Foundation Wing far more relaxed with
only a handful of staff and a light
force of guards still to SCP 035 it
didn't matter how many there were it was
enough to make a start the wrinkly hands
of its new host clenched sharply the
foundation staff all suspended in midair
suddenly exploded each one of them every
researcher and guard erupted into a
fireball burning white hot like heated
metal before fizzling out there was no
nothing left no scraps of clothing no
remains they just weren't if it wanted
to SCP 035 would have thrown its head
back and laughed maniacally in some
strange way Casten thought that might
have been better instead it was silent
the mask's wide soulless grin conveying
its Twisted Delight well enough it
turned to face the wall thick layers of
concrete standing between it and the
outside world and began stepping forward
so completely casually but it was
unnerving with its first step the walls
of the cell surrounding the SCP 035 and
SCP 343 hybrid as well as Casten began
to crumble away with the second the
corridor outside did the same falling
apart without any exertion of effort
from the masked God each and every step
further more of the building around them
was chipped away carving a path through
rooms and research stations towards the
edge of the site it was as though the
Concrete and brick work the den heavy
materials that constructed the facility
suddenly had the consistency of wet sand
and SCP 035 and its new host were the
tides coming in washing away all in
their path no longer in pain but his
body distorted Beyond repair Casten
forced himself up off the ground at last
weakly he limped after the creature
thinking in vain he had any chance to
stand against a being with the unbridled
power of a God and the infinite cruelty
and Malice of the possessive mask if he
could just get close Enough cast in
thought he could tear the mask away
freeing the old man he wouldn't be able
to stop himself from putting it on a
second time but perhaps it was better
that Casten wore it and let its black
ooze melt him down at least the wise
kindly old man would be able to get far
enough away from SCP 0 35's influence
and casden could at least in part put
this right after all he'd stolen the
mask from the foundation this all
started with him as the hybrid reached
the farthest wall the barrier turned to
Glass and shattered the combined monster
looked out over the waiting helpless
world through US SCP 343 the possessive
mask had control over chaos and creation
alike and nothing on earth that could
challenge it not the foundation not
Humanity not even other anomalies
lifting its still lifeless grinning mask
upwards the sky darkened the deafening
boom of Thunder ringing out above forked
bolts of deep orange lightning cracked
across the atmosphere as what was left
after the foundation facility dissolved
behind the masked God though it was
facing out towards a world that would
soon crumble as easily as this building
the creature could see everything far
beyond where it stood the lives of
billions upon billions all at once it'
watched plants grow While others wilted
animals born only to die humans living
out their ritualistic existences each
one of them gradually heading for the
same fate and through all of that it saw
a hand and trembling behind it reaching
for its mask Casten he was so close
fingertips just about to brush the
porcelain surface of SCP 035 when
suddenly the mask and the old man
wearing it were gone tasten turned
around in confusion only to find it was
now standing behind him it reached out
one of the wrinkled bony old hands and
touched a single finger on his forehead
Caston blinked and he was back back
before the heist before any of the
wanton Devastation had begun he
recognized the room he was in and sat in
the very same place where his mysterious
benefactor had approached him with a
seemingly impossible job to steal a mask
from the SCP Foundation sure enough
sitting across the table obscured by
Shadow was the client but behind his
eyes Casten was trapped helpless as he
watched himself live out the same events
that had led to the mask being placed on
the face of God he couldn't change the
course of history couldn't avert the
apocalypse that was already happening
all he could do was watch his heart
sinking as his client pushed a file
across the table opening it to reveal a
photograph of his Target the thing he
wanted cast in to steal SCP
035 the possessive mask and meanwhile
back in the new hell of its own Creation
The Mask was having some real fun
Shirley woke up screaming louder than
usual this time ba Shirley's wife bolted
upright as though someone had just run a
20,000 volt charge through her her dirty
hand clasped over Shirley's mouth until
the awful sound stopped she whispered
baby it was just a dream Just a Dream
Shirley fell into a terrified silence
trying to regulate her breathing they'd
been hiding in an abandoned Apartment
block for 3 days now waiting for the
roads to clear so they could take the
chance and move forward be keeping
closer to the ground scuttled over to
one of the smashed out windows she
stared down onto the street 30 ft below
midnight no stars cars crashed up
against one another from the initial
panic and thank God none of those things
down there she breathed a sigh of relief
and returned to Shirley Gathering her up
in her arms and giving her a reassuring
squeeze her body was still trembling
what happened in this one vea asked
Shirley exhaled and closed her eyes we
were close now she said we're so close
ba it was the dream that began this
journey the Quest for the last safe
place initially ba had thought it was a
Fool's errand there were no safe places
in this world anymore nowhere that the
Sun or its terrible monsters hadn't
touched but surle insisted otherwise
she'd seen it in her dreams a place of
almost mythical Wonder a vast and
complex facility away from the light
sight 19 Shirley and Bae grabbed their
backpacks and Shrugged them on it was
best to set off now get a few hours of
walking under their belts and find some
shelter before the sun came back up in
the meantime all they needed to do was
avoid the monsters lurking out there it
was an interesting tradeoff Once Upon a
Time years and years ago when the sun
changed there had been billions of those
things they were people once until the
new light touched them and turn them
into these slimy Abominations there was
a time you couldn't look out your window
without seeing hundreds of them
slithering past you then they started
coagulating becoming these huge
mountainous masses of gloopy melted
flesh it was nice that there were fewer
now made them easier to avoid easier to
sneak around but if one of those things
found you you were dead or more likely
you were about to be something so much
worse than dead the two women Trek down
the side of the road keeping to the
Shadows even in the dark dark they were
on the edge of the city now and it
wouldn't be long until they were in the
wilderness Pro being away from a
population Center meant lower odds of
being attacked by one of those monsters
con fewer places to hide when the sun
came up in the meantime all they could
do was keep walking and hope it was an
almost Supernatural mixture of luck and
skill that had gotten them this far
they'd known each other for 4 years when
day broke and everything went to hell
but they'd only been married for about a
month it' been a hell of a post
honeymoon wakeup call so many had been
changed in the initial panic and so many
more had been destroyed by what came
after but these two weren't just anybody
in fact it was the specific combination
of skills and knowledge these two
possessed that kept them alive for this
long in the world that came before ba
had been a soldier who done two tours
abroad and seen active combat multiple
times and shirely had been a doctor
Rising through the ranks of a local
hospital between them they could fight
for and heal one another despite
everything and in those early years
that's all it had been they were always
moving always avoiding the Terrors
outside and the tyranny of the sun they'
avoided the dangers that had destroyed
so many others but they' never dared to
hope hope was lofty impractical it got
people killed they'd only ever tried to
survive the immediate avoidance of death
was a practical goal anything else was
just confetti until of course Shirley
had started having the dreams some were
just fragments like sifting through a
stack of photographs in the middle of a
deep fog others were full narratives
like movies in her head viewed in the
first person but all of them were about
the same thing she and ba needed to make
it to a place they called site 19
something about it was familiar like a
thing she had heard years ago perhaps
from those strange broadcasts that were
on every TV screen during the initial
chaos oh and of course there was one
more element in the dream the one thing
that made it seem more like a nightmare
in this part of the dream she was
already in sight 19 and walking down a
long dark hallway somewhere far away
from the Sun there are a series of heavy
reinforced doors along the wall next to
her each one of them had a number on
them advancing as she got further down
the hall 029 030 031
032 that's when she'd hear the voice
that awful terrible voice
shirle oh
surely come
closer don't you want to see my face I'm
smiling surely I'd like for you to see
it she' reached the door marked
035 at which point the door slowly
creaked open even after all the
terrifying things they'd seen in the new
world this somehow paralyzed her with
fear every time it was a kind of dread
she'd never experienced before something
that looked like black water would start
seeping out from the opening door then
footsteps getting closer a shambling
figure would emerge from the open door
it was hard to make it out fully in the
dark but somehow she just intuitively
knew what was coming towards her it had
a stark white face like a mask with
nothing but Darkness where the eyes
should be down below the body seemingly
heavily injured and dripping with the
same black water was one she recognized
her own she couldn't move the MK figure
this smashed version of her kept getting
closer dripping with more and more of
that black water it was shaking almost
vibrating then she realized it was
[Music]
laughing see you soon Shirley it said
can't wait for you in Bay to visit and
that was when she woke up screaming
somehow despite the Grim ending some
part of Shirley knew that she and ba
needed to get to site 19 only there
would she be safe and perhaps even find
the answers about how all this horror
had even transpired they were already
risking their lives out here every day
wouldn't it be worth it to find the
truth the duo continued to trudge
through the night it was they think
their lucky stars a relatively
uneventful Journey they encountered one
of the flesh beasts on the edge of town
but they were able to hide inside a
nearby bus depot until it slithered on
gibbering incoherent Madness after
waiting to make sure it was gone the duo
left the city and ventured out into the
Badlands Shirley continued to insist
that the legendary sight 19 from her
dreams was definitely close by now ba
looked up to the sky and chimed in I
hope you're right honey or you and me
are fried eggs Shirley and B walked for
another several hours each becoming more
slightly anxious that the Sun would rise
before they reached ample cover and
everything they worked for would be
taken away from them the terror
persisted until against all odds a huge
black shape started to emerge along the
horizon the sight of it made Shirley's
eyes widen in amazement that's it ba she
said sight 19 just like it was in my
dreams they passed the chainlink fence
around the perimeter approaching this
large seemingly abandoned building like
it was the lost city of El Dorado ba was
astonished she loved Shirley of course
and had faith in her beliefs but
something about a place prophesized in a
dream actually being real was honestly
nothing short of a miracle the two of
them approached the Fortified front door
and heaved it open together Against All
Odds they could see light inside the
building they still had power here
nowhere had power anymore maybe this
place really was salvation after all as
the two closed the door behind them they
noticed that the windows all around them
were shuttered it must have been some
precautionary measure against the new
Sun smart whoever these people were
they' thought ahead they'd have have
some kind of preparation for all of this
so Bae couldn't help but wonder where
had they all gone now as the two
ventured deeper into the building ba
unholstered a handgun that she'd been
keeping in her jacket it was no good
against the flesh monsters but it was a
worthwhile deterrent against other
desperate people out on the road lucky
for them she hadn't needed to fire it
yet other than the power being on
somehow the place seemed abandoned they
traveled from room to room office off es
filing areas what seemed like
Laboratories libraries rest areas there
was no real indication of what these
people whoever they were actually did
around here after searching through a
few different files all written in
almost incomprehensible shorthand and
code surley at least found a name to put
to these people the SCP Foundation was
it some kind of Charity they ventured
deeper until they found a hall marked
d-class bunks inside they found bunk
beds stacked on top of each other enough
to hold hundreds of people ba wondered
aloud whether this was some kind of
Secret paramilitary outfit it was the
one thing that might explain everything
they'd seen here today and in all
fairness she was at least partially
right okay ladies hold it right there
Shirley and Bay turned around to see a
man in an orange jumpsuit standing a few
feet behind them he was carrying an
assault rifle and training it on both of
them he was a tall imposing man and yet
he was shaking Bay lowered her gun
neither She nor Shirley said a word
you're human right he said voice
trembling slightly what Shirley replied
just answer the damn question there was
a tense pause where nobody there seemed
to know what might happen to them next
the stranger's finger started curling
around the trigger it was ba who broke
the silence we look human don't we she
said another moment passed the gun
rattled in the stranger's hands he
exhaled lowered the barrel taking a more
relaxed stance sorry he said can't be
too careful kind of stuff they used to
keep in here it'd give you nightmares
I'm Mike by the way he approached
tentatively shaking Shirley and Ba's
hands just to prove to them that he
wasn't the kind of guy who liked to Gun
Down random women he asked them whether
they were hungry and when they told him
they hadn't eaten anything but protein
bars in over a week he told them he was
about to show them something incredible
the sight 19 break room not long after
that that Shirley ba and Mike were all
sitting around enjoying some defrosted
Hot Pockets at that moment no three
course meal cooked up by a five-star
Chef could ever even compare as they ate
together Mike told his story the people
who used to run this place believe me
they were nut jobs sure back in the day
I wasn't such a nice guy me and some
other Knuckleheads we needed the money
so we robbed a few places people got CAU
out in the crossfire next thing I know
I'm on death row and then these men in
white coats that came and told me I
could get a commuted sentence if I came
and took part in some experiments that's
how they got me into their house of
right here if Shirley and Bay
hadn't lived through the apocalyptic
hell of when day breaks they might have
not believed Mike he told them about how
this SCP Foundation used to use humans
in experiments subjecting them to all
the monsters they had locked up down
here there was this giant reptile that
couldn't be killed some freaky statue
that had sna your neck if you stop
looking at it but the one that
frightened him the most the one that
haunted his dreams ever since he got
here the mask Shirley said aloud lost in
thought Mike was taken aback how had she
known what he was going to say it did
nothing to reduce his fear when she told
him that she'd been dreaming about the
mask for over a month now stark white
with black water dripping from it
everyone was silent for a moment ba and
Mike just stared at Shirley equal parts
amazed and frightened Mike cleared his
throat and told Shirley that in the
years that had passed since day broke
the population of site 19 had slowly
dwindled monsters had escaped the flesh
beasts had slithered in and taken others
over time most of the staff had either
died changed or left all that was left
here was him and The Mask luckily for
him he'd never been directly cross
tested with it because those who got
tested with the mask never came back
sometimes he could hear it whispering
ing in his dreams trying to leak itself
into his mind Drip by drip poisoning his
soul the one Saving Grace was that being
a mask it couldn't exactly walk up and
tap you on the shoulder all you needed
to do was stay away from it and you'd be
fine the mask couldn't hurt you on its
own the three of them carried on talking
for the last hours of the morning night
had become day and day had become night
it was the easiest way to survive these
days or at least survive as is yourself
ba and Shirley told Mike how they' met
in college all those years ago Mike told
them the story of how he managed to
survive by hiding in a broom closet
while some gangly white monstrosity
chased down and slaughtered the rest of
his bunk mates the tiredness took them
all again and they decided to bed down
in the d-class bunks they were more
comfortable than the bed rolls that
Shirley and baay had been sleeping on in
abandoned buildings for the last year or
so to Mike this place had been a living
hell once upon a time but now for for a
brief period in this terrifying New
World it could be Heaven Shirley drifted
off to uneasy sleep trying her best to
ignore the Whispers In what only felt
like a few moments her eyes fluttered
back open she was in a new place but one
that felt oddly familiar a long dark
hallway bordered on one side by a series
of iron doors she turned her head
slightly eyes still adjusting to the
darkness the number on the door next to
her read 02 27 further down the hall
Shirley saw a dark figure Standing Tall
shoulders Broad and back erect as a
ballet dancer as her vision came back
into Focus she saw a shock of orange it
was Mike wearing that same orange
jumpsuit he was standing about 10 or 15
ft away staring in the opposite
direction Mike surely said operating on
the foggy half logic of a dream he
didn't respond with growing concern she
started stepping closer Mike that's when
she noticed something else Black Water
pulled around Mike's feet the sight of
it stopped her in her tracks and froze
the breath in her throat with an almost
audible Creek Mike turned around a
grinning white mask covered up his face
hello
Shirley it said so lovely to finally
meet face to face a I bet you're so glad
you ran into me after all sleepwalking
can be dangerous Shirley screamed and
ran in the opposite direction wasting no
time at all she heard the slow measured
footsteps of Mike wearing the mask
behind her it was in no rush it walked
like a MK killer in a horror movie Why
run the voice said I've got all day and
I know you can't leave while the Sun's
up darling you and your beloved are all
mine it's only a matter of time somehow
despite her being so far ahead the voice
sounded like it was right next to her
ear like it wasn't speaking out of its
mouth it was just talking directly into
her brain with every syllable her mind
started to slow like the mask's voice
was tar seeping in between the gears
soon enough her legs stopped working
Shirley was frozen in place hearing the
footsteps of the MK mik behind her her
brain was flooded with dark thoughts
death pain torture grief the final
smothering of all hopes and happiness
there was really nothing like it like
every nightmare she'd ever experienced
being collected into one terrible Elixir
and poured onto her mind so this was
what that horrible mask could do soon
enough the Mast Mike had passed her and
turned to look directly at her face
there was an awful smell like chemicals
and burning flesh she turned her gaze
downward seeing that it looked like
Mike's body was somehow m melting away
from all that black water it was like
acid Mike was a weak host the mask said
as if it was replying to her thoughts he
won't last much longer but that's fine
I'm looking forward to taking you for a
world dear Shirley and when your hands
are mine you can only imagine the
terrible things I'm going to do to your
beloved Bay with them surely with all
all her willpower was able to move her
mouth enough to force out the words
don't you dare touch her the monster
laughed just like it always did in her
[Laughter]
dream that's not your choice to make
anymore it said the MK reached for her
with Mike's melting fingers fizzling
away with all that black slime getting
so close to caressing her tender cheek
all that awful silence was only broken
by the sound of a soft clicking behind
it then a gunshot passing through the
back of its stolen head the mass turned
more shocked than anything to see ba
standing there wielding Mike's old
assault rifle and aiming it with deadly
accuracy before the mask could breathe
another poisonous word ba opened fire
releasing a volley of bullets into the
last of its melting body as it staggered
back into the darkened hallway Shirley
watched in astonishment as the creature
fell Mike's body splattering into a
puddle and sending the mask itself
skittling down the hallway maybe it was
just a trick of the mind but she could
swear the mask was frowning now not
smiling Bae breathed to Cy relief and
said I'm thinking it's probably better
if this place stays abandoned Shirley
who hadn't quite regained Her speech
just yet just smiled nodded and embraced
ba they shared a kiss just happy to
still be together and Alive despite it
all come Nightfall they left again in
search of another place the possessive
mask remained there laying on the floor
of some Anonymous site 19 hallway just
waiting for some unlucky weak-minded
Survivor to wander in and try it on the
storms were unlike anything anyone had
ever seen But the worst part wasn't just
the deadly Gales wind howling powerful
enough to knock down buildings like rows
of dominoes and lift the remaining
debris of cities up into the air as if
all that destruction weighed nothing and
it wasn't just the lightning those arcs
of crimson forking down from above if
one struck the ground near you and one
almost always did the sheer force of it
would knock you off your feet the last
thing you'd feel as you flailed
helplessly in the air was the Relentless
pain of your body being disintegrated by
the energy of the blood red lightning
until there was nothing left of you for
anyone to find yet somehow that wasn't
the worst part either
and it wasn't even the noise of it all
either that deafening cacophony of
booming Thunder and wild hurricane force
winds so loud nobody could ignore it all
underscored by the screams of a world
lost in suffering and Madness no the
worst part of it all was the sky whether
anyone looked up where there had once
been that clear calming blue was now a
swirling mass of nightmares many were
surprised just how much they missed
turning to that sky that odd Universal
comfort it brought the knowledge that no
matter how Bleak things got the sun
would set on every bad day and Rise
Again to Mark the start of another
filled with potential that promise of a
Future No Matter How uncertain was
replaced with a reminder of one thing
that this new darker day had no end
there was no Sunrise or Sunset no night
or day all that uncertainty and
potential was replaced with certain Doom
represented by a sky that looked like a
river of blood deep Reds and black
swirled and thrashed above like the
Raging Waves of the ocean casting bolts
of lightning down at the Earth not to
mention what else would occasionally
drop from that Blood Stained Sky nobody
had much information about how this all
had started how the world had become
such an unrecognizable hellscape cynic
would say that the world was already
hell long before the sky turned red
although there wasn't much time for
sarcastic jokes like that nowadays as
far as the few human beings that had
survived could remember the day
everything changed had been little more
than an ordinary day on planet Earth One
Moment things were normal people were
working tirelessly at their boring
nine-to-five jobs somewhere in the world
others had long since fallen asleep in a
different time zone then all of a sudden
it appeared few survivors had actually
seen it for themselves and even fewer
had lived to tell the Tale But rumors
and Whispers spread from Camp to camp
dispossessed people huddling together in
the ruins of houses or in abandoned
subway tunnels that would hear the
stories and somehow deep down in the
fearful recesses of their hearts they
all knew despite never having seen it
that it was real the Mast God when it
stepped upon the Earth it walked like
any other person would its body even
appeared to be human an aged older man's
body wrinkled and elderly although not
completely decrepit yet it was his face
or what covered it that really instilled
that sense of fear and dread in anyone
that heard the rumors that being wore a
mask a porcelain comedy mask the kind
commonly associated with ancient Greek
Theater it had a fixed unnerving
expression a wide smile of Twisted Glee
it was almost as if it was getting some
sick enjoyment out of all the chaos and
destruction that had befallen the world
like it was pleased with its own
handiwork a thick black substance oozed
from the mask too adding to its
unsettling appearance as streaks of what
looked like tar trickled down the chalky
white surface it leaked out from
underneath as well dripping over the
Bony shoulders of the old man that wore
it not one Survivor that heard the
stories of this monster understood what
it was or where it had come from but as
if by some defic influence they all knew
it was responsible for creating the hell
they now lived in that knowledge kept
them hidden kept them afraid and kept
them from fighting back as had always
been the case even before this
apocalypse had been Unleashed on the
world the only people who knew the truth
were the ones who had been working for
the SCP Foundation they had more than
their fair share of answers about what
had happened and who or what this maske
wearing Menace was but naturally kept
that information secret from The Wider
world not that there was much point in
keeping secrets anymore after all there
was hardly much of a world left for the
foundation to hide things from and even
fewer for former Personnel who had
lasted this long even then there was
only a handful at the SCP Foundation who
knew everything that had led to the
current catastrophe most of the
researchers and guards that had been
going about their ordinary duties
running tests on contained anomalies or
patrolling the site where a certain
possessive mask was housed the next
thing everyone there knew was the
blaring noise of alarms mobile task
force Troopers racing down the hallways
their Commander might have yelled
something about a break-in someone
having gained access access to the
supposedly secure Foundation facility
and stealing one of their anomalous
objects but not everybody even those
working in the same building would have
overheard that they definitely didn't
miss what happened next though as
further alarm sounded alerting the staff
on site of a containment breach the
facility itself was torn apart in a
flurry of chaos Personnel researchers
security MTF soldiers were being
incinerated burned until there was
literally no trace of them left
something stepped through the very brick
work of the building itself smashing a
hole through every room it passed until
it burst out of the side then all of a
sudden the alarms wer the loudest sound
something else started deafening the
foundation staff who were still standing
the world outside had become even more
chaotic the sky had turned red and all
around people were being killed
structures decimated cities Blown Away
in moments naturally this wasn't the
first time the foundation had stared
right into the face of an XK Class end
of the world scenario given the
widespread presence and surveillance
they had around the planet it didn't
take them long to learn of the horrors
that were unfolding the key word there
was that they had a widespread presence
as in past tense they thought they had
enough resources to retaliate too word
quickly spread throughout the various
arms of the SCP Foundation informing The
Wider organization of the situation and
urging them to work as one to enact a
plan to stop what was happening all they
knew for certain was that SCP 035 had
been removed from containment also known
as the possessive mask the object was
known to have its own sentience and an
innate ability to telepathically
influence unwitting victims into wearing
it however the mask also secreted a
corrosive black substance which normally
dissolved the body of anyone who put it
on by itself SCP 035 was nowhere near
powerful enough to unleash a global
catastrophe though unfortunately it had
managed to influence someone who was
that powerful into putting it on another
anomaly while to the untrained eye SCP
343 could easily be mistaken for an
elderly human man those at the
foundation knew that the fact he was now
wearing the possessive mask was some of
the worst news they could have ever
received although none of the
researchers working for the SCP
Foundation in fact not even the 05
Council knew if this was true the
colloquial nickname for SCP 343 was God
he not only claimed to be the sole
creator of the entire universe but had
also exhibited extensive reality warping
abilities Advanced even for an anomalous
being his powers seemingly had no known
limit and how they could be used to
alter the world around him although the
old man himself seemed to be a passive
kindly Soul rarely causing active harm
to other beings under normal
circumstances of course normal
circumstances didn't include having the
corruptive SCP 035 on his face
effectively putting the mask in the
driver's seat and allowing it to use SCP
343's powers to lay waste to anything
before it the foundation quickly
diverted their considerable assets to a
Brute Force retaliation in the hopes
that a full-scale assault on the
combined creature would somehow force a
separation of the possessive mask from
SCP 343's face the tricky thing about
this situation was God's powers and the
fact that he was an immortal ageless
being of potentially incomprehensible
form all meant he couldn't be harmed
causing external damage to him was
extremely difficult that was good news
in some regard after all the foundation
didn't want to kill 343 if they could
help it they knew he wasn't acting on
his own accord but his indestructibility
also meant that the corrosive goo that
was secreted from SCP 035 had little to
no effect on its new impervious host
that meant it could keep going keep
unleashing hell and stopping it was
going to take a lot of Manpower
fortunately the SCP Foundation never had
any shortage of people to throw out a
problem and their ethos didn't really
Place much value on human life they
mobilized every mobile Task Force at
their disposal every one of them filled
with ranks of highly trained Elite
operatives among the foundation forces
were even MTF agents who had themselves
been altered through anomalous means
means their bodies augmented with
technology and cybernetics or their
strength specially enhanced deploying
the full might of their amass forces the
SCP Foundation took the fight to SCP 035
with the goal of stopping its reign of
terror and freeing SCP 343 if possible
the hybridized maske wearing reality
warper had already caused considerable
damage since it had started its Rampage
although its motivations were far from
political the wearer of the anguish mask
had begun with a devastating show of
power wiping numerous cities off the map
while the rest of the world scrambled to
find some way of responding the Mast God
teleported itself across the globe
destroying Central governments and
further crippling their own
opportunities to initiate an armed
response in short this meant the
foundation's move was to be Humanity's
Last Stand their final chance to stop
SCP 035 from its current course of
harnessing the Wise Old Man's power to
turn the world into its own personal
nightmarish playground to say there was
a lot writing on the MTF assault would
be an understatement as with saying it
went badly when met with times of defeat
the old rather morbid adage of Fallen
Soldiers being sent home in bags is
often applied but if the massed hybrid
had sent the foundation its MTF troops
back to them encased in body bags then
that would have been far Kinder than
what it actually did the collected
mobile task forces the foundation's own
private Army were mobilized to
Washington under the influence of the
possessive mask SCP 343 had wiped out
not only the main seat of power in the
United States but the Pentagon as well
disabling the country's defenses
suddenly a mass of aerial transports in
ground Vehicles came hurdling towards
the crater it had left behind as it
turned to look the wide grin of
satisfaction on SCP 035 became a long
frown thanks to its new host's
omniscience it instantly recognized the
foot soldier of the organization that
had kept it caged for so long as the
amassed mtfs marched towards it the
masked Gods stepped out to meet the
oncoming Army one being against
thousands of troops if not tens of
thousands if the mask had affixed itself
to the face of any other anomaly those
soldiers might have stood a slim chance
the combined creature casually raised
the Bony arms of its host body the
foundation forces breaking into a charge
the very second they saw it move like a
tital wave they rushed towards their
target only for each individual
operative to quickly realize that they
had stopped moving they were still
running legs Still In Motion but their
feet had been lifted off the ground
plucked from the very Earth they each
had stood on the mtfs were stuck in
midair defying the forces of gravity and
unable to free themselves collectively
the foundation's Army looked to SCP
035 its tragic porcelain frown having
switched back to the wide grin
punctuating the sick satisfaction it was
about to take from what came next it
gave a click of God's lean fingers and
each of the MTF troops it had suspended
in midair were shredded at the molecular
level their bodies erupted with a spray
of deep red Visa each and every one of
them being pulled to pieces from the
inside out flesh bone and blood melting
away breaking down becoming Ash and then
atoms and then nothing it took around a
minute not that it was terribly exerting
for SCP 343's Powers but just because of
how many troops the foundation had sent
to try and stop it a mighty show of
force and all for nothing with their
mobile task forces decimated like a row
of helpless Tin Soldiers the SCP
Foundation had lost its primary method
of fighting back but they were far from
safe from the Mast God's reach thanks to
its host SCP 035 wasn't all knowing but
allseeing and able to be anywhere and
everywhere in the blink of an eye it
began hunting the surviving pockets of
the foundation Personnel out of nowhere
it would teleport into wherever they
were hiding and turn their bodies inside
out or rearranging the functions of
every orifice on their faces only to
vanish like a ghost leaving no trace and
no survivors the braver ones tried
desperately to come up with some new
plan a revise way to stop a creature
that could be anywhere and do anything
on the other hand the foundation leaders
ship the more highly ranked members like
the OverWatch Council went to the ground
plenty of them had contingency plans in
place for Armageddon and they were
prepared to wait out the Apocalypse in
their own secluded Safe Haven but with
the foundation all but gone that's when
the monsters got loose no longer having
anyone to guard them to maintain their
specific specialized containment
procedures the scps still held at
Foundation sites were Unleashed on the
world Untold Horrors came spilling out
of the ruined facilities each one now
acting as its own Pandora's Box bursting
its lock and having its terrible
contents lay waste to the planet already
a wash with chaos a lot of the anomalies
thrived in the world that SCP 035 had
created once they were finished fighting
amongst themselves in the struggle of
escaping their containment soon there
were packs of SCP 745 running wild on
the ruined highways using their
bioluminescent lights to hunt human
survivors who were attempting to make
the dangerous Trek across Open Country
meanwhile a plague began spreading
amongst other camps of these
post-apocalyptic humans a strange
disease that seemed to cause people to
rapidly grow extra teeth over producing
them until SCP 4910 the grinner could
catch up to them then there were the
scps that fled the nightmare that the
Mast God had made of the world any that
could travel between Dimensions or
remove themselves from this layer of
reality quickly absconded to avoid the
chaos some just went about their
business as if nothing had really Chang
changed the plague doctor mostly kept to
himself traveling from place to place on
foot only stopping when he encountered
people Afflicted with the pestilence
before moving on in search of others
some of the anomalies tried to help
people rumors spread among some Survivor
camps of a halfman half Cactus leaving
them food and supplies in the night with
a note that read from your friendly
neighborhood cactus man there weren't
many who dared to oppose the creator of
this dark new world but some anomalies
sought to challenge the rule of this
combined creature perhaps they thought
SCP 035 and SCP 343 couldn't possibly be
all powerful as the story said that it
would be easy to kill the king and
assume control over his kingdom of chaos
there were plenty of other anomalies
that had floated the idea not just the
other reality warpers but those that had
figured out that if they separated the
mask from its host then this world would
become their hellish Paradise to rule
over so long as SC P 343 didn't
instantly undo all the damage but there
was one that didn't want control it
didn't even necessarily mind the whole
world had been turned into a walking
nightmare it just wanted to stand
against the hybrid of malicious mask and
all powerful deity out of spite based on
nothing but pure hatred for any and all
other forms of life other than itself
and it was that confrontation that would
serve as a warning to the rest of the
scps now freely roaming the world CP 682
slithered out into the open claws coated
with a fresh coating of blood from its
latest Slaughter wetting the countless
layers beneath that had already dried
the harded destroy reptile had tracked
the scent of the possessive masks oozing
black secretions bringing the Beast ma
to porcelain face with a combine being
responsible for distorting the very
fabric of the world already knowing the
foul lizard was near thanks to its
host's foresight SCP 035 Visage had
already been locked in that unhappy
Grimace dreading the approach of the day
it would have to face the tenacious
irritating regenerative reptile it
turned its host's body to face the huge
Beast the trails of black stre down its
frowning face looking like Angry tears
staining its carved off white skin the
two exchanged no words SCP 682 had no
doubt this pairing of corruptive mask
and pass of God already knew why it had
come looking for it and it was right the
possessive mask had long been looking
into the mind of SCP 343 to prepare it
knew it wasn't one of the old man's
children in fact God had completely
denied ever being responsible for the
creation of the unkillable monster there
was almost no strategy even with the
infinite power of its host's reality
warping abilities that SCP 035 could
definitively kill SCP 682 building up to
a charge the reptile swiped at the Mas
God its Talons narrowly nicking the
porcelain surface of the mask the very
second it tell teleported out of the way
reappearing behind the monster SCP 035
compelled its host body to lift its
elderly arm and decimate the Beast the
same way it had to the foundation's
forces with a fearsome hiss the
reptile's body was pulled apart it
growled with anger annoyed and enraged
more than deterred its strong scaly
limbs quickly regenerated bone and
muscle regrowing to replace what the Mas
God had torn away SC SCP 682 gave a
swipe of its tail knocking the Mast God
a few F feet away reeling him the
anomalous hybrid teleported yet again
this time to inside the Monstrous
reptile shrinking down to almost
infinitely small the mask and God
wrenched apart SCP 682s atoms ripping up
strand after strand of its very DNA
physically trying to unmake it on a
cellular level on the outside the
creature's body disintegrated as it
roared feeling its very genetic material
breaking down only for it to rapidly
reform just as SCP 34 3 wearing SCP 035
reappeared in front of it there was no
way for the Mast God to kill the monster
despite how much it tried sending it
hurdling Into the Fire of the sun
punching it into other dimensions moving
it down the recursive stack of reality
to make its existence Little More Than
Fiction eventually the possessive mask
had to reconsider the problem at hand
even with infinite power the unkillable
still remained unkillable rather than
ask whether that meant its own power was
truly unlimited it instead resolved to
the only option it had left with a snap
of its host's fingers the combined
creature sent the hard to kill reptile
away far away universes upon multiverses
of distances were put between the Mast
God and SCP 682 turning back towards the
destruction it had wrought on this world
SCP 035 knew that the regenerating
reptile would be back but for now it had
more chaos to unfurl have we tried
stopping it of oxygen veren asked
sounding bored with the conversation
already yes we have Dr Kelly grumbled in
reply we're able to create a vacuum
remove 99% of the air from its
containment chamber and its life signs
dropped I'm sensing there's a butt
coming next the research assistant
sighed rolling his eyes typical but 682
was able to fill the chamber with a gas
mixture of ozone chlorine Xenon and uh I
forget the foundation doctor answered
getting more and more agitated point is
it was able to form and expel chemicals
even without any active life signs H
it's almost like there's a reason we
caught the hard toy reptile I just wish
I could figure out what it was beden
retorted making no attempt to mask his
sarcasm giving a dry chuckle much to Dr
Kelly's annoyance it was a debate that
had been going on for what felt like the
entire history of the SCP Foundation how
could anyone possibly kill as CP 682 the
creature had long been one of the most
infamous anomalies that the foundation
had ever encountered so much so that the
hearted destroy reptile was synonymous
with the organization but the Mandate
still stood that it needed to be
destroyed as soon as someone was able to
figure out a way although they hadn't
quite exhausted every possible option
just yet most of the researchers were
running short on ideas thinking up a
plan to kill 682 was made all the harder
knowing the creature had surv rived and
regenerated from every single previous
test if there were something some
neutralization method that was going to
work surely they would have found it by
now uh maybe we should just leave it
researcher assistant for heeden
suggested I mean we've got it sitting in
a tank of acid perpetually melting it as
fast as it can reconstitute its body
while it's like that 682 is hardly a
threat to anyone hardly a threat Dr
Kelly scoffed clearly more than
perturbed your dead rag Mita
as long as that monstrosity continues to
live it poses a constant threat to every
single human being on this planet hell
every life form in the world it hates
everything else that much look I'm just
saying that after Ree and Foster were
discussing this issue and maybe the
whole his voice drilled off for a moment
after the situation that led to maybe
it's better if we leave 682 alone it
seems that every time we turn to come up
with a solution to a reptile problem
something always goes wrong the whole
thing's curs St like a big joke where
the punchline is more and more of us end
up dead while 682 keeps on living just
despite us you have no idea what you're
talking about Kelly yelled infuriated by
such a suggestion that trying to destroy
682 once and for all was little more
than an exercise in futility hey hey
take it easy his subordinate replied
trying to calm Kelly down you got to
admit doc it seems more impossible than
well all the other impossible things
that we see in this job it's an
important mission of the SCP Foundation
for Eden Dr ground holding back his rage
to safeguard Humanity from anomalous
threats I'm convinced we just need to
find the right set of variables the
right conditions or equipment and I we
can kill this thing once and for all but
where do we go from here I mean we've
tried Conventional Weapons other
anomalies if other powerful scps can
kill the sing what chance do we have
maybe it's a case of finding the right
one Dr Kelly theorized SCP 738 and SCP
743 both failed we couldn't even fit 682
in the booths of the Clockworks if we
wanted to so back to the drawing board
what haven't we
tried why don't we just throw SCP 035 on
it reeden remarked clearly making
another snide sarcastic joke that thing
wouldn't even fit over 682s big lizard
snout it would probably just slide off
onto the floor hold on Kelly replied
pondering the idea for a moment since
being assigned to the site containing
SCP 682 studying the reptile up close
he' become determined to figure out some
way to finally kill it it would make him
a legend in the history of the
foundation being the one who did what
they had failed to do for so many years
that might just work doc I was kidding
at Doc his research assistant replied
turning to see that Dr Kelly was already
racing down the corridors of the
facility that is an absurd suggestion Dr
bride answered when Kelly came rushing
up to him hastily explaining his plan
for
scp-682's termination no listen here
Jack please just hear me out Kelly urged
yes SCP 035 is a dangerous anomaly in
its own right but it's also deadly to
the wearer it secretes that substance
that corrodes the body or of whoever or
whatever wears it right and you came up
with the idea to play such an object
over over the head of a creature that
can regenerate and adapt to almost any
form of damage BR retorted before the
other Foundation doctor could finish
that's precisely my proposal he replied
look we already keep SCP 682 contained
in aat of acid for safety right Melt
Away its body before it has a chance to
fully regenerate keeping it in this
Perpetual state of healing and
sustaining damage at the same speed now
what if we go the whole hog let SCP 035
take control of the reptile until the
mask drenches it in Black goo melting it
down for good and you've considered the
other possibilities right bright as
trying his best to walk away from Kelly
as they spoke that SCP 035 takes full
control of 682 and is granted an
immortal host that might not degrade
under its secretion there's a far higher
likelihood that SCP 035 wouldn't even
fit on the reptile its face is the wrong
shape the possessive mask is made for
humanoid faces not reptilian ones yeah
but the reptile is able to adapt is it
not Kelly fired back correct
and if we allow it to adapt to SCP 035
we could even have a greater monstrosity
on our hands a hybrid of the possessive
mask and the heart to destroy reptile oh
my God Jack brigh shouted fed up with
having to listen to Kelly's outlandish
idea a being like that would be hellbent
on destruction I'm sorry Dr Kelly the
the answer is no please the other doctor
begged just send it up the chain on my
behalf I just need clearance to run one
test I can take it high
but I'm telling you now the answer won't
change Dr Bri admitted agreeing just to
get Kelly to back off sure enough later
that very same day Dr Kelly received a
notice from the senior research staff
his superiors within the foundation Dr
Kelly we have learned of your proposed
experiment for terminating SCP 682
unfortunately after confirming we have
decided this course of action would pose
too great a risk to the safety of
civilians as well as our own staff here
at the SCP Foundation additionally Dr
brgh has raised concerns with us us
about your recent obsessive Behavior we
would kindly ask you to attend a
mandatory psychiatric evaluation
tomorrow at 1500 hours to assess and
potentially reassign you given your
interest in using SCP 035 we feel in
your current state you may be at risk of
being influenced by the psionic effects
of the possessive mask the message from
the research supervisors was still open
on Kelly's computer terminal when ver
heeden went to check on him it looked
like the doctor had started typing a
response you idiots want to psych B me
you want to ignore the actual present
threat to the foundation the longer we
keep that reptile alive the more
everyone and everything is at risk but
you want to persecute me for trying to
come up with a radical solution if
you're all too cowardly tacked then I
have no choice but to Kelly had left the
rest unfinished without hitting send
although it didn't take much of a reach
for his research assistant to realize
that his sentence would have ended with
do it myself his heart pounding
regretted ever suggesting using the
possessive mask as a joke joke veren got
up and ran racing through the corridors
as fast as he could towards the
containment cell for SCP 035 he had a
sick feeling in his stomach that he
might find Dr Kelly already there acting
out of a fit of uncontrollable anger and
what he thought was a moral obligation
to destroy SCP 682 Dr Kelly had stolen
some amnestics from the foundation store
rooms lacing two cups of coffee with the
memory altering drugs he'd offered the
hot beverage to the pair of armed guards
stationed outside the room where SCP 035
was held accepting what they thought to
be an act of kindness from a foundation
doctor both security officers had
quickly forgotten why they were standing
around so idly luckily the friendly
Foundation doctor had reminded them they
had reached the end of their shift and
were free to go and punch the clock with
no reason to question him the guards
wandered away leaving Dr Kelly alone
with SCP
035 then The Whispers started they
seemed garbled unintelligible at first
but the closer that Dr Kelly grew to the
GL last case the clearer the voice of
the possessive mask started to sound so
it hissed I hear you have a reptile
problem doctor the loud wailing of
alarms told veren he was already too
late SCP 035 had breached containment
thanks to a rogue Dr Kelly no doubt the
research assistant cursed his own big
mouth for even mentioning SCP 035 as an
option for destroying the reptile
although he could have never known Kelly
would take it so seriously as a
suggestion but now the doctor's
obsession with being responsible for
finally ending SC SCP 682 was running
rampant turning a corner the research
assistant stopped in his tracks he had
quickly realized it was pointless
heading towards the SCP 035 containment
chamber Dr Kelly would already have what
he needed from there but there was only
one place he'd be heading once he had
the possessive mask in toe taking the
corresponding Corridor veren raced
through the foundation facility toward
the direction of the room housing the
the vat of acid where the hard to
destroy reptile was waiting a trail of
bodies scalded and scorched with a
viscous black substance told him he was
on the right track it was the same
corrosive secretion that leaked from the
possessive mask meaning that either
Kelly had forced someone to wear it or
Worse had been manipulated into putting
it on himself if SCP 035 had convinced
him it might have the answer to killing
the reptile then little could have
stopped Dr Kelly from bringing it to SCP
682 whom the mask could use as its next
host and to researcher veren's horror it
looked like exactly that was about to
happen as he arrived at
scp-682's containment cell Talk stop he
yelled in desperation this has gone too
far please Dr Kelly turned to look over
at his assistant his face now obscured
by the carved exaggerated porcelain grin
of the possessive mask its smile was one
of Twisted Glee like it was taunting ver
heeden for even trying to stop it the
corrosive liquid was was leaking out
from underneath it spilling down Dr
Kelly's bare neck and onto his shoulders
rapidly melting away everything it
touched meanwhile the acid from
scp-682's tank was starting to be
drained away and the monster was
beginning to stir hooking two fingers
under the edge of the porcelain comedy
mask Kelly started to Wrench It off his
face compelled by SCP 035 The Mask knew
of the foundation doctor's plan and was
far less interested in helping kill 682
as it was using the reptile as an
immortal host finally one that wouldn't
degrade in the same way so many others
had before with the last of his strength
he pulled the mask away his brain dead
body succumbing to its injuries and
dropping the mask right into
scp-682's tank as SCP 035 landed on the
creature's head it let out a wild pain
War black streaks of corrosive secretion
began to Trail down the reptile making
it thrash at the pain of the substance
burning and dissolving the outer layers
of its thick K the noises Led Out by 682
were enough to Pulver hen's eyes away
from Dr Kelly whose body had collapsed
lifelessly he had died trying to bring
an end to a monster the foundation had
never successfully destroyed yet another
life lost in the pursuit of killing the
unkillable reptile as the life hting
lizard thrashed about looking like it
was about to burst free of its Cage in
Rage the research assistant shot across
the room to reverse the acid draining
from the tank the foundation security
team arrived in the containment room
just as the acid tank had very nearly
been fully refilled although he had no
idea if it would have an effect
verheiden had stopped it just short of
also submerging the possessive mask in
the acid 2 which still seemed to be
precariously balanced on the 682s head
not covering its face as a cleaning crew
arrived to remove Kelly and the bodies
he'd left in his wake the foundation had
to come up with a plan for removing SCP
035 without their staff falling into the
acid vat no no no hold on heeden
insisted I know this started as a joke
between the dark and me and I had no
idea he had taken it so seriously but
look he pointed to the inside of the
tank the gigantic reptilian monster was
completely still while the possessive
mask still let streaks of its corrosive
substance drip over its head and it
looked to be taking effect still
dissolving every part of the reptile it
came into contact with maybe it could
work the research assistant mused
Retreat to a safe Zone the security
Chief instructed we are to await orders
on further course of action if you want
to observe you'll have to do it from a
distance falling back it seemed the
entire Foundation was waiting with
baited breath to see what would happen
next through back and forth radio
chatter with their superiors neither
veren nor the security forces seemed to
know how to proceed from the outside it
looked like SCP 682 and SCP 035 were at
a stalemate but in the back of their
minds everyone had to wonder how long
was this going to last what nobody
noticed however was the unique way in
which which SCP 682 had adapted to
coming into contact with SCP 035 a lump
had formed on the topmost part of the
reptile's head its scales had parted
allowing for the fleshy growth to swell
until it was roughly the size and shape
of the average human face it lacked any
of the usual characteristics no eyes
nose or mouth but seemed to work as a
way to better Mount the possessive mask
since it couldn't fit over the hard to
destroy reptiles long lizard-like
features additionally what looked like
the black corrosive substance from SCP
035 leaking on to 682 and melting away
at the mask's new host actually seemed
to be another adjustment the creature
had made to its own physiology instead
of dissolving the reptile the substance
was being absorbed diverted to a
specially formed gland inside the
monster that was now safely storing the
corrosive goo within its own mouth but
further within beneath all the external
and even internal changes occurring to
SCP 68 2's body a far greater change was
taking place deep in the recesses of the
Twisted murderous mind of SCP 682 was an
intruder a presence that the reptile
could feel trying to bore its way in to
not only make itself known but to take
over the pair of them the
consciousnesses of both these anomalies
were battling each other for Supremacy
the heart to destroy reptile wanting to
retain control of its own body and mind
and the possessive mask Desiring total
dominion over its new found host SCP 682
had long been known to have a high level
of pionic resistance halting the spread
of SCP 035 telepathic influence however
because the reptile's body had adapted
and acclimatized to the mask's corrosive
secretion it meant 035 was able to
persist hanging on and still trying to
force its way into the reptile's mind
you hate them all so much the voice of
SCP 035 echoed from inside the hard to
destroy reptile's head don't don't
bother it thought back in reply you are
alive that makes you as disgusting and
putrid to me as the rest of them but
think what we could achieve together the
mask whispered for a moment the reptile
considered an alliance both it and The
Mask possessed a shared hatred towards
Humanity although 682s extended to all
other forms of life including the
sentient comedy mask it now wore though
even a temporary cooperation between the
two might have its benefits SCP 682 had
no intention of remaining bound with the
possessive mask for longer than it
needed and in much the same vein SCP 035
was only proposing such a partnership to
avoid being removed from perhaps one of
the few beings that could wear it for an
extended period of time without being
dissolved entirely outside in the
containment chamber the foundation
Personnel had been instructed to remove
SCP 035 from the reptile despite
concerns that the sudden removal of the
Mask would cause the monster to enter a
rage State the possessive mask was now
fused with the Flesh of SCP 682 through
its specialized protrusion and the
foundation's fear was that the longer
the pair of anomalies stayed bonded the
more the hard to destroy reptile would
be able to adapt against other powerful
scps so research assistant ver heeden
had been ordered to increase the acid
contents of the tank to full capacity
hopefully burning the tissue connecting
the reptile and The Mask to each other
before the white porcelain of SCP 035
could under the rising acid a clawed arm
reached up over the boiling vent and
pulled the research assistant under
screaming he landed in the tank with a
splash followed by a rapid hiss
clambering up out of its containment
tank the hybrid of SCP 682 and SCP 035
roared as the combined creature freed
itself from containment in the chamber
below all hell broke loose security
officers reached for their weapons not
even waiting for the order before they
open fire bullets pained off the
porcelain comedy mask that was embedded
in the top of the reptile's head barely
scratching the surface and unable to
pierce the monster scales some guards
charged in only for the reptile to spew
a molten black substance from the
specialized glands in its mouth it was
channeling the corrosive secretions from
SCP 035 into a weapon the resulting ooze
dissolving the security team as they
approached stopping their futile attempt
to recontain it before they could even
try witnessing this knowing their own
imminent deaths were near researchers
and remaining Foundation security turned
heel and ran for their lives as
Containment Breach alarms blared through
the facility although both anomalies
were secretly intending to betray one
another for now SCP 682 and SCP 035 were
free to unleash their combined monstrous
form on the humans they both hated the
most their captors the SCP Foundation
having your ordinary life
unceremoniously changed Forever Without
a moment's notice is something that
people can often find themselves hoping
for anything to break life's monotony
and change circumstances to make them
more interesting although when that
change comes in the form of being
trapped in an endless Ikea Outlet it's
not exactly the different kind of
circumstances that people usually hope
for that was the situation that had
befallen Winston not too long ago what
started as a simplistic straightforward
shopping trip with the goal of
purchasing some affordable stylish
Swedish Furniture had resulted and him
having to adopt a completely different
lifestyle you see Winston was one of the
untold number of people to have an
encounter with SCP 3008 better known
colloquially as the infinite Ikea
appearing as an ordinary store those
entering the doors of SCP 3008 find
themselves in an unending Labyrinth of
aisles upon aisles filled with flatpack
homewear it can be quite the System
Shock of course especially when people
that find themselves inside the infinite
at Ikea learn there's no way to escape
even by retracing their steps back the
way they came doing so they'll only be
met with a disheartening realization
that the entrance isn't where it was
upon their arrival now at first learning
that you've lost your entire life and
are doomed to spend the rest of your
days inside a limitless Ikea is
admittedly a lot to take in your friends
family job all your worldly possessions
are now unreachable and everyone back
home might likely spend many years
wondering what happened to you but it's
not all bad news as previously mentioned
Winston wasn't the only one to find
himself in this predicament over the
years countless people have found their
way inside the infinite Ikea given how
expansive the interior of the
never-ending store was there has never
been a way to know for certain exactly
how many people have come to reside
within SCP 3008 but it's enough to
populate the number of small settlements
that these survivors have been able to
establish Inside by innovatively
repurposing the materials around them
these individuals have found themselves
to be the new denisons of SCP 3008
imagine whole towns constructed from
chairs and tables that have been used as
building materials to provide a place of
sanctuary to those that need it when
they first arrive in the infinite Ikea
sure it takes a pretty big adjustment to
this new lifestyle but luckily SCP 3008
provides for its inhabitants by
automatic replenishing the food within
its canteen naturally it only offers
items that are on the Ikea menu but
that's at least a consistent source of
food and nutrition for those dwelling in
its aisles with food already taken care
of people inside SCP 3008 didn't even
need to work that was the strangest part
that Winston found himself having to
adapt to when he first got to the
settlement of cookware named after the
nearby sign that hung from the ceiling
nearby denoting one of the many
departments of of the store it was odd
to him how friendly everyone was how
much the people trapped inside 3 2008
cut off from the outside world forever
seemed happy there were many who'd been
there for the longest that even claimed
it was a better sense of life than out
there in the real world inside the Ikea
there was a strong sense of community
settlements helped each other out with
construction and because everything was
provided for no one had any need for
selfishness or greed after all there was
plenty of food to go around and money
had no relevance ironic given they were
all living inside a huge Furniture Store
witnessing all of that helped Winston
adapt to his new life inside SCP 3008
and made him feel a lot better about
being in this predicament the only real
thing anyone inside the infinite Ikea
had to worry about was the threat of the
staff these were the tall faceless
humanoids with elongated arms and legs
that roam the aisles of the furniture
store while wearing distinctive IC Ika
uniforms most of the time they remain
docile paying the human survivors little
attention that is until the fluorescent
lights above dimmed signaling the
beginning of nighttime the staff usually
became aggressive repeating the ominous
phrase the store is now closed please
exit the building and attacking anyone
they came into contact with thanks to
their Ingenuity the survivors in the
Ikea had constructed barriers around
their settlements to keep the staff out
and that did the trick repelling The
Faceless employees that come at night
but little did anyone inside SCP 3008
realized that simple barricades wouldn't
stop an entirely new threat from
entering the store to disrupt their
peaceful way of life for outside the
infinite Ikea Something Wicked was
stirring meanwhile at a facility
belonging to the SCP Foundation a
researcher by the name of Corbin Donell
had recently been assigned to SCP 035
also known as the possessive mask this
white porcelain mask could shift between
a comedy grin or a tragic frown it also
had the nasty trait of being an evil
psychic artifact that could manipulate
anyone around it into placing the mask
over their face at that point SCP 035
would take full control of its wearer
making them into a host for the mask
itself so would you like to take a guess
as to what happened to researcher Donell
the voice in his head that persuasive
whisper it wouldn't leave him alone all
day long it was there but whenever
Corbin was near SCP 035 it got louder
and as the days he was studying the
possessive mask went on the whisper
became a shout the screams to put on the
mask were taunting him keeping him awake
at night tormenting him all through the
waking day until eventually he'd had
enough given that SCP 035 produced a
corrosive black substance that usually
melted anything around it the mask had
to periodically be taken out of its
containment case so that the container
housing it could be replaced and it was
during one of these transfers that
researcher Dell calmly swept in pushing
away the guards taking it out of its
melted case before they could place it
in a new one the aggression from the
researcher caught the security Personnel
by surprise as did what he did next not
caring what the possessive mask would do
to him Corbin lifted the white porcelain
to his face he wasn't even aware that
the Containment Breach alarms were
sounding all that noise sank into the
background as the psychic voice in his
head got louder than it ever had before
there wasn't even so much as a split
second awareness from researcher denell
of the Searing pain as the dark sludge
oozing from The Mask made contact with
his skin melting his face as he wore SCP
035 by that point it was already too
late the possessive mask had full
control Corbin's body wasn't his own
anymore although it still moved walking
quickly out of the room and through the
halls of the foundation facility the
researcher beneath was already dead
there was only SCP 035 piloting its
newest host to freedom of course while a
Containment Breach was still an urgent
matter the foundation knew that SCP 035
is biggest weakness was itself the black
secretion that poured out of the
possessive mask would melt anything it
came into contact with and would
ultimately cause the body of its to melt
into nothing once that happened it would
be far easier to recontain as
cp035 someone would merely have to pick
it up and place it back in the
containment case however SCP 035 knew
this too The Mask itself was cunning it
hadn't just picked researcher denell at
random to be its new vehicle it wanted
him specifically because of his previous
posting before he had worked with SCP
035 Corbin had been stationed to observe
any potential changes at the entrance of
SCP
3008 as it stayed firmly on the
researcher's face using him to carry
itself out of the foundation site it had
been trapped in SCP 035 was scouring the
remnants of Corbin's mind it used its
innate psychic abilities to plunder the
depths of his brain looking for
information the location of SCP 3008 was
right there stored away safely and
researcher donel's memories as was the
way to to get there and on top of that
the reason SCP 035 had taken such an
interest in making it to the infinite
iea during the foundation's many years
of study and exploration of SCP 3008
they came to learn that not all of the
survivors inside the infinite Ikea had
originated from the same universe the
current theory was that the entrances to
this endless Furniture Store existed
simultaneously in multiple realities
meaning that the people now living
alongside each other inside SCP 3008
were actually from varying different
worlds across the Multiverse now if you
were incredibly cunning incredibly
clever and Incredibly sick of being held
captive by the foundation then perhaps
you could figure out a way to navigate
your way through the infinite Ikea you
could enter through the front door in
one universe and then exit into another
and of course that was what the
possessive mask was planning to do as it
approached the main entrance of SC P
3008 the black sludge leaking out of the
Mask had almost destroyed what was left
of researcher Corbin Dell it wiped more
of the corrosive secretion onto the
guard stationed at the infinite Ikea
melting through them as SCP 035 made its
way inside first things first The Mask
knew it had to find itself a new body to
Pilot before Corbin expired and it
didn't take long for the possessive mask
to happen across an unwitting candidate
between the aisles of flatpacked tables
at around the same time this was
happening Winston having long since
gotten used to the Rhythm of Life inside
SCP 3008 was on his way to the food
court he knew the route by heart now and
as he strolled closer he was pondering
over what he'd help himself to today
from the menu but it was while making
his way there that he noticed something
or rather he noticed not something that
he usually did there were no staff
anywhere around although they did not
pay the survivors any mind during the
day when the of the Ikea were on Winston
knew that the staff members were always
present there were usually a couple
Milling about the aisles he had to pass
in order to get from the settlement of
cookware to the Food Hall but today
there were none and while this wouldn't
usually be any cause for alarm it kept
playing on Winston's mind as he sat down
to eat his plate of Swedish meatballs
he'd been inside SCP 3008 for such a
long time that he'd become accustomed to
the routine of living there and the
absence of the staff immediately stuck
out as as something that was out of its
usual place finishing his food Winston
asked around talking with his fellow
residents of the infinite Ikea asking if
any of them had encountered any of the
tall faceless staff members on their way
to get their meals each and every one of
them that he asked from varying
different settlements all answered the
same that they hadn't spotted any staff
all day as much as they were A Minor
Threat to the human beings living inside
the infinite Ikea the absence of the
store's only other residents kept
playing on Winston's mind whatever was
going on the staff seemingly Vanishing
couldn't mean anything good and so he
decided to venture out into the aisles
to figure out what exactly was going on
what he found was unlike anything anyone
had ever seen in SCP 3 2008 before it
took Winston several long and uneventful
hours to catch even a momentary glimpse
of a staff member he almost felt like
someone trekking through a forest
looking to get a sighting of big foot or
some other elusive urban legend but as
the third hour became the fourth he
spotted a hint of movement between the
aisles following at a safe distance
listening out for the slightest sounds
Winston couldn't help but think he
detected the noise of something heavy
being dragged along the stone floor
peeking out from between the aisles he
saw them a huge group of Staff members
were all huddled in a display dining
room only there was something different
about all of them they still retained
their recog iable tall and humanoid
shapes with long disproportionate limbs
but there was something smeared over the
staff a dark oily black substance that
seemed to melt through the floor as it
dripped off them from his Hiding Place
Winston soon saw where that substance
had originated from the thing being
dragged across the floor was another
staff member looking more normal than
the rest one of the others covered in
the corrosive sludge was gripping it by
the colar of its Ikea polo shirt and
bringing it through the group meanwhile
the ordinary creature was thrashing and
flailing its lengthy arms around trying
to get free it was dragged up to a staff
member in the middle of the group which
turned and shocked Winston at the
strange sight of it this staff member
evidently the leader had a face or
rather it was wearing a mask SCP 035 was
now firmly AIX to the Slender faceless
being its expression locked in a wide
grin that seemed to convey a twisted
sense of Glee it black secretion didn't
seem to be affecting its new host in the
same way it usually did the body of the
staff member it was now piloting didn't
seem to dissolve as the uncorrupted
staff creature was presented to the Mast
leader SCP 035 compelled its Newfound
followers to restrain their prisoner the
workers within SCP 3008 didn't have much
in the way of their own free will or
even personalities to speak of they did
however seem to share some sort of
connection to each other a hive mind of
sort so presented with a powerful
psychic Force like the possessive Mask
The Entity had been able to not only
take over one of the staff members as
its new host but spread its influence to
the others and while Winston watched
horrified it unknowingly demonstrated
this the captive staff member was
grabbed and held by the others its long
arms and legs pulled apart the huddled
group lifted it up off the floor so that
it couldn't free itself and run off into
the endless aisles of furniture wearing
SCP p035 the leader extended an arm
black ooze dripping from it the droplets
burning Holes in the Floor as it reached
towards the faceless head of the
restrained staff member it placed a
large hand over the faceless head of the
captive more of the corrosive secretion
passed on to the newest addition to SCP
035 is growing Army as the black
substance spread over the staff member
so did the influence of the possessed
mask Force its way into another vessel
I'm telling you I know what I saw
Winston protested after recounting the
events to the other settlers back at
cookware there's something else out
there something new and dangerous and
it's infecting the staff oh that's
ridiculous replied Bryce one of the
survivors who had been there much longer
I've been here for years and I've never
even heard of such a thing they yelled I
saw it with my own eyes Winston argued
it has a small army of them already
under its control even if what you're
saying is true someone else chimed in
what does it matter you've already got
barriers to keep the staff out and they
only attack a KN anyways surely even if
this mask thing really is in control of
them now who cares as if on Q one of the
Lookouts at the cookware settlement
started frantically trying to get
everyone's attention they pointed to the
ominous glow coming from just beyond the
nearby aisles filled with wardrobe
frames an orange flicker was visible
even Under The Lights of the store which
were still on although blocked a little
by thick plumes of black smoke rising up
towards the ceiling and that's lighting
the lookout said in shocked disbelief
stating the name of another nearby
community of survivors that was named
after an Ikea store Department something
must have happened over there Bryce
declared uh maybe it's an electrical
fire that's gotten out of control it's
them Winston said solemnly it can't be
them the older Survivor snapped the
lights are still on it's still daytime
in the store and the staff never
attacked during the day I don't think
the rules are the same anymore
frustrated Winston continued to argue
there's no telling what that mask did to
them uh perhaps Bryce was trying
desperately to come up with a suggestion
but was clearly grasping at straws what
if this mask can be Reon with if it's
more intelligent than the staff we can
we can negotiate uh there must be
something it wants what do you think it
wants it wants this place this Ikea and
now it has control of enough staff to
form a small army you think it's just
going to stop there it's coming for all
of us and it won't stop until it's got
the whole store under its control and if
it has to wipe us out to do that well it
looks like it's not hesitating so what
do we do a voice called meekly Winston
turned to see the town's folk of
cookware had gathered all looking up at
him with terrified Expressions on their
faces he gazed back at each one of them
then looked back over at the smoke now
towering over where lighting had been
and was now in Flames who knew how many
of the settlers there were still alive
and how long it would be before SCP 035
and its new Army did the same to
cookware something had to be done we
need to get the word out Winston
announced to the other survivors I need
our fastest to run over to the other
towns in the store you each take one you
pass on the message and then you come
back you know your way around well
enough so avoid anywhere you'd normally
see staff even if they haven't been
corrupted we can't chance it why do we
tell the other settlements somebody in
the crowd called you tell them what's
going on you say that something has come
here to threaten this Ikea and our way
of life this place isn't where any of us
first came from but it's all our home
now it's provided for us but now it
needs us us to defend it Winston
explained and how exactly are we going
to do that Bryce asked the lights had
gone out but although night had fallen
it wasn't Dark Yet standing with their
fellow survivors from numerous other
settlements the residents of SCP 38 had
fashioned flaming torches from the legs
of Ikea desks and tables and that wasn't
all they were carrying makeshift weapons
some had Spears crafted using curtain
rails with sharp kitchen implements
fashioned to the end others had wardrobe
doors in their hands to act as
rudimentary Shields they were hardly
Warriors but as an army of corrupted
staff members lurched out of the
darkness towards them each Survivor of
SCP 3008 knew what they had to do at the
front of the army towered the staff
member with SCP 035 on its faceless head
the possessive masks wide grin had
shifted now a long frown almost one of
disgust at the amassed settlers who
opposed it as it raised an elongated arm
to command its horde Winston raised a
curtain rail spear into the air for Ikea
he yelled as the residents of SCP 3008
charged alarms go off all around the
facility things descended into chaos so
quickly of course the staff of the SCP
Foundation are extremely familiar with
the horrors of a Containment Breach by
now but this was something exceptional
two anomalies had joined forces in an
unexpected fashion neutralizing some of
the weaknesses that the two of them
usually experienced needless to say this
was bad more specifically 74 staff
members were dead already several
different mobile task forces had already
been dispatched to hunt down this
terrifying new anomaly but none of them
knew where it was hiding in the depths
of the site little did they know this
deadly new hybrid had already escaped
the SCP Foundation and was already on
its way towards a nearby population
Center that's where the real fun would
start but before we get to all that
Carnage let's rewind the clock a little
and find out how This Disaster started
some things just go great together like
peanut butter and jelly milk and cereal
or clicking subscribe when you're
watching a video by SCP explained but
for every match made in heaven there's
also a match made in hell like being
covered in sugar water while you walk
past a wasp nest or doing tricks with
your awesome Zippo lighter next to a gas
pump or most horrifying of them all a
combination of SCP 106 and SCP
035 of course the reputations of these
two horrible creatures are well known
and well feared enough on their own
scp-106 is a humanoid Abomination also
known as the old man capable of walking
through walls and entering his own
private pocket Dimension where he
practices his predilection for pain to
its full potential and then there's SC
cp035 also known as the possessive mask
this is one of the most powerful and
dangerous psychic entities that the SCP
Foundation has in its vast collection
some of its more minor unpleasant
qualities are things like the fact that
it constantly drips corrosive black
slime or the fact it immediately reduces
you to a state of brain death when
you're foolish enough to wear it on the
more severe end of its abilities is its
power to crawl into the mind of anyone
around it slowly Whispering whors into
their mind until they're completely
under its control or utterly broken it
likely has designs on world domination
or at the very least to plunge the human
race into an unimaginable pit of Eternal
suffering the one Saving Grace is the
fact that 035 corrosive slime slowly
destroys the body of its hosts limiting
the purview of each one of its Reigns of
Terror but occasionally there are
wonderful terrible exceptions to the
rule speaking of terrible our story
began chronologically with SCP 106
showing one of its rare signs of
activity this naturally caused waves of
panic to rock through the researchers
and security staff of the site they'd
need to grab a d-class then plug in and
warm up the femur breaker they'd also
need to mobilize groups of on-site
guards with powerful flashlights to slow
the gnarled old monster down but by now
as cp16 had gotten wise to the
foundation's techniques he wouldn't make
himself so easy to capture this time he
wanted to have the proper time to enjoy
himself
scp-106 got up and phased through the
nearby wall his cell was never easy to
escape they filled it with strange
shapes and running water just to confuse
his wretched old mind but once he was
out he was out he avoided the hallways
instead just phasing from wall to wall
until he reached a different block of
containment Chambers that's where the
Fateful meeting would take place it
wouldn't be the first time he'd wandered
into other containment cells his battle
with SCP 682 perhaps being the most
famous but this time something was
different the room he just faced into
didn't contain some huge writhing
monster or another humanoid Beast it
contained instead a glass container on
top of a Podium the walls coated in
deadly telekill alloy to keep its
prisoners immense psychic power sealed
in but now that SCP 106 was in the room
standing meere feet away from the
grinning white mask inside the glass
container there was nothing keeping the
two of them from having an extremely
fateful conversation the first thing
scp-106 noticed was the black liquid
leaking from The Mask strange it seemed
to perfectly match his own secretions
hello there good sir it isn't often I
have visitors in here and even less so
visitors who are as handsome as you the
mask said speaking to directly into the
old man's frail fractured mind I don't
believe we've ever been acquainted come
a little closer and remove the glass box
I'll be able to hear you better that way
come on come on don't be shy the old man
felt something about the mask was
distasteful even to a creature as
Despicable as
scp-106 something about the mask just
seemed slimy metaphorically as well as
literally and yet it found itself
stepping forward towards the glass case
almost as though he was sleepwalking how
was the mask invading his mind like this
he'd always been one of the more
mysterious creatures in the foundation's
containment and yet SCP 035 had slipped
into his mind like a warm bath on some
level it frightened him yes yes that's
wonderful come closer dear boy you're
doing so well the mask said as the old
man reached forward and began lifting
off the glass case I think I I'd look
rather good on you don't you agree let's
cover up that nasty old face of yours
you'll look positivly spiffing old chap
just do exactly as I say and this is all
going to go
wonderfully the old man picked up the
mask somehow not even in control of his
own body anymore and almost electrical
power seemed to pulse out of the mask
and through the old man's rotting
fingertips the old man was a SA
but he'd never before encountered this
kind of utterly malicious intelligence
this was a mind geared to commit almost
incalculable evil and while the old man
was wondering how exactly he felt about
that he was already lifting The Mask up
to his face and watching the universe go
very very dark outside a small army of
foundation security operatives armed
with flashlights and assault rifles were
charging through the halls trying to
trace the movements of the old man for
recapture back in the old man's cell a
confused serial arsonist was being
shoved into the femur Breaker by a group
of nervous and impatient researchers
none of them knew they were dealing with
an entirely different Beast down here
now eventually the security team found
the last Rusty Scorch mark on the wall
of a containment cell belonging to SCP
035 before they could even comprehend
the terrifying implications of this
horrible scenario they charged into the
cell in hopes of stopping in it but by
the time they were in there both the Old
Man and the mask were already gone well
not entirely suddenly the guards in the
room felt an odd sense of calm wash over
them not a true authentic calm but an
artificially induced one like the
lulling of a cattle while a bolt gun
descends towards their foreheads The
Mask psychic influence had pacified them
making them perfect prey for the rotten
hands reaching out from the ground and
pulling them down into into Oblivion the
guards outside heard the most horrific
screaming they circled the door
terrified aiming everything they had at
the entryway but it wouldn't be enough
soon enough this new hybrid Beast SCP
106 wearing SCP 035 emerged and began
its Onslaught it had the immense
physical abilities of 106 bolstered by
035 diabolical intelligence and ability
to Cloud the minds of its victims
inhibiting their capacity to run away or
fight back but most frightening of all
because SCP 106 was already adapted to
resist the effect of its own corrosive
mucus it was also perfectly able to
sustain The Mask as a host without ever
melting and falling apart see what we
mean about a match made in Hell how do
you like my new body Gentlemen The Mask
asked its voice dripping with malicious
Glee it isn't much to look at I know but
you're about to get very well acquainted
with its collection of of charming
abilities and The Mask stayed true to
its word it rampaged through the
containment site waling through walls
like a gleeful School child with the
heart and mind of the Devil Himself
leaving a pile of melted tortured
corpses in its wake researchers guards
janitorial staff nobody was safe and
with every killing the rest of the staff
became increasingly afraid only
strengthening the psychic hold of the
Mask it was having the best stay it
could remember in a long long time the
site director and his team put out a
Mayday for all available mobile task
force units to descend onto the area and
help them deal with this deadly new
threat but by the time they were on
their way the mask and its new scp-106
body had already had its fun with the
foundation even when they activated the
femur breaker nothing happened the mask
was far more interested in the pain it
could cause outside and far too
intelligent to be lured back into
imprisonment by such a simple trick
instead the hybrid made its way out of
the nearby perimeter wall finding its
way to a heavily armored Foundation
ground vehicle and sliding in through
the door like a ghost the operative in
the driver's seat was immediately
terrified by the monster suddenly
sitting next to it but then the mask
psychic effects took over his mind he
became a calm Placid little servant just
like all those other Mortal fools I feel
like a change of scenery old sport The
Mask said to him take me out to the
nearest city it can be the one of your
choosing I feel like having a little
night on the town oh it's been far too
long you know the hypnotized driver
nodded and punched the gas the guards
were too busy controlling the aftermath
of the chaos within the site to even
notice the creature they were chasing
had already escaped and if it reached a
nearby City then the chaos cruelty and
Madness it was liable to release would
be the biggest mess the foundation would
need to clean up in quite some time
which was precisely what the malicious
mask had in mind meanwhile Dr Robert
Scranton woke up in a dark room well he
wasn't sure if it was a room but it was
definitely dark he rose to his feet in
this strange black void surrounded on
all sides by Blackness it wasn't the
belly of SCP 3001 the dreaded red
reality again no this was something new
and what's more he had no no idea how on
Earth he'd gotten here Dr
Scranton said a cruel mocking voice
behind him turn around old chap it's
been far too long since I've seen you in
the flesh well in a manner of speaking
at least confused Dr Scranton turned and
saw a Vaguely Familiar sight SCP 035 the
possessive mask floating in the dark
behind him what on Earth was happening
here he wondered oh you really don't
don't remember do
you the mask said with a spiteful laugh
replying to a thought he'd never voiced
aloud we're in your mind doctor as it
turns out you're harder to erase than I
thought perhaps you're buried so deep in
the psyche of that
monster no matter I'll get you
eventually how strange Dr Scranton
thought this must be his mind playing
tricks on him somehow he raised a hand
to scratch his head quick physically and
only then realized that his right hand
was gone simply vanished from the end of
his wrist The Mask gave another sick
laugh oh it's already started I told you
I'd get you
Scranton the mask cackled with Glee I
never normally get to delete a mine
slowly oh this will be amusing where's
Anna Scranton asked suddenly wondering
about the safety of his beloved wife he
couldn't help but worry when this got
another cruel laugh out of the
Mask oh don't you remember Robert The
Mask said through
Giggles you killed her you killed her
with your toxic Embrace she died
terrified of you and with that all the
awful memories came flooding back back
in the real world things weren't any
less horrifying when the vehicle had
finally made its way to the nearby City
the masked old man had unceremoniously
murdered its chaur and decided to go for
a little exploration it had been so long
since it felt the sun on its pristine
white porcelain such a beautiful day
outside it couldn't wait to kill some
people around here it began its Rampage
in a dark alley snatching some homeless
people and unfortunate passers by
through the graffi stained stone walls
by the time it was done with them there
weren't even any bones left but this
would only be the start of the masked
old man's horrific Rampage through the
city next he invaded an office building
and decided to unleash his Grizzly wrath
on the people within some were pulled
through the ground while chatting at the
water cooler others were dragged through
the walls as they went to refresh their
coffee some were simply sitting at their
desks getting on with their daily work
when a dark silhouette appeared behind
them some turned around saw the creature
and screamed immediately others remained
in ignorance and only screamed when an
acidic rotting hand curled around their
shoulder but every single one of them
screamed eventually by this point the
SCP Foundation had started sending all
the mobile task forces in the area to
the nearby city after receiving reports
of unexplainable disappearances and
murders Panic was starting to spread and
that Panic was only making the
nightmare's psychic abilities of the
Mask even stronger the challenge would
be intercepting SCP 106 and removing the
mask before became too powerful for them
to do anything about it if they didn't
they could be looking at a loss of life
on a massive scale which was exactly
what SCP 035 hoped to indulge in a young
Barista was having a stressful day at a
nearby Boutique coffee shop she retired
to the staff bathroom to splash some
water on her face and reenter herself
she side and looked up from the sink
into the mirror to see if her makeup was
running and then screamed a dark figure
was standing right behind her it looked
like a rotting human corpse dripping
with black slime and wearing a grinning
white ancient Greek comedy mask I'm not
interrupting anything am I the masked
told man said amused soon after the dark
presence had Spilled Out into the coffee
shop the psychic powers of the Mask
caused its victims to be paralyzed with
sheer Terror unable to escape its cruel
hands the death toll of the day had
already risen to over a hundred and the
masked old man had no intention of
stopping that's when several police
cruisers skitted to a halt in front of
the coffee shop cops disembarked from
their cars and pulled out their handguns
step out of the store with your hands up
one of them yelled over a megaphone any
sudden moves and will blow you to
Kingdom Come This made the Mast old man
laugh oh how very adorable not long
after he was driving a police cruiser
further into town with a pile of Dead
Cops left in the street behind him this
was shaping up to be such a wonderful
day he never wanted it to end back in
the pitch dark of the mindscape Dr
Robert Scranton was looking a little
worse for where both of his legs had
disappeared along with one of his eyes
and much of the rest of his right arm
his remaining eye was weeping
remembering how his Embrace as the old
man had killed his beloved Anna he'd
lost his humanity and become the worst
kind of monster the kind who even hurts
the people he loves most SC SCP 035
floating in the darkness was still just
laughing at
him oh you're pathetic Scranton it said
look how little is left of you you
haven't even been human in decades why
not give up what little is left you're
mine now and soon you're going to be
nothing at all and Dr scr kept crying
because he feared the mask was right
back in the city the stolen police
cruiser pulled up in front of a
preschool and the masked old man got out
this would be the perfect place for his
next Little slice of fun straightening
himself out he began walking to the
school knowing that with the extent of
his psychic powers nobody would be
strong enough to run away they'd all
just have to sit there and suffer just
like Dr Robert Scranton Goodbye old man
The Mask said said to him I'm tired of
talking to you now Dr Scranton was ready
to give up and let himself disappear but
then something occurred to him Knowledge
from his foundation days I I I must be
wearing you Dr Scranton said I must be
wearing you Scranton reached up to his
face with his remaining hand grasping at
something suddenly the face of the
floating mask Twisted into an infuriated
frown what do you think you're doing it
said it's too late wa Robert but
Scranton wouldn't be deterred he gripped
something invisible over his face and
began to tug even though pulling on this
invisible mask on his face was agonizing
the whole void around him began to shake
and quiver including the grimacing SCP
035 Scranton just kept pulling stop that
you idiot it roared stop it stop it stop
it you're going to ruin everything you
but it was already too late Dr Scranton
murmured
I'm sorry Anna and gave one last yank
that's when everything went white back
in the city it thankfully wasn't long
until a group of mobile task force
agents was able to locate the two
anomalies scp-106 was sitting
cross-legged on the grass outside of a
preschool where thankfully nobody had
been hurt and was just staring off into
space in his Trembling Hands was another
familiar sight of frowning SCP
035 now go check out the whole story
what if scp096 wor SCP 035 and SCP 106
The Old Man origin theories for more
Tales concerning today's terrifying
anomalies